SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES TO
ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY
I WILL AGAIN BE MAKING SOME
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO EXPLAIN
THE PROCESSES THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC. FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THIS PROCESS WE
TRULY APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE
WHILE I GO THROUGH IT ONCE
AGAIN FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE
TUNING IN FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME. SO I'M GOING TO COVER THE
TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS FOR
TODAY. IN RESPONSE TO THE COVE
IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY IN TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING TONIGHT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING.
AND WE'VE MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO THE LEGIT
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS FOR
GIVE ME. WHAT CONDUCTING THE
HEARING IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS
THE HEALTH AND THE SAFETY OF
THE PUBLIC AND OUR EMPLOYEES.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS
WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS. TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AS WELL AND
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE. THE ACCESS
CODE IS. THREE THREE EIGHT ZERO
FOUR SIX SEVEN. WHEN WE MOVED
PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN
YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME YOU
MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ANY FEEDBACK YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU WERE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
SO WE THANK YOU IN ADVANCE FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE. MAYBE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE ARE HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. ALL EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS.
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO THESE NEW ONLINE
TOOLS. SO PLEASE BE PATIENT
EVERYONE AND- WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE IS HEARD.
AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF OUR COURT
REPORTER. I WILL ASK ALL
SPEAKERS MY COLLEAGUES AND
WITNESSES UNLIKE TO SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY. AND IF I
NEED TO I WILL STOP YOU OR ASK
YOU TO START OVER GO SLOWER SO
THAT WE CAN GET YOUR TESTIMONY
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT. SO
BEFORE WE BEGIN TODAY'S AGENDA
WE WILL ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND
A REMINDER TO MY COLLEAGUES YOU
WILL NEED TO TURN YOUR
MICROPHONES ON FOR THE ROLL
CALL. AND EVERY TIME WE VOTE SO
AT THIS POINT MAN SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BROKE
PRESENTS WILL PRESENT KAMLAGER
YOU'RE A LONGER HERE LAYERED
HERE HERE HERE FAITH HERE BATES
HERE ATKINS HERE ATKINS HERE.
SO COLLEAGUES IF WE COULD
BEFORE WE GO TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR I
WOULD CERTAINLY ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES
NOT REQUIRED TO APPEAR MAKING
SURE WE DON'T NEED TO SEPARATE
OUT ITEMS C. OR D. IF EVERYONE
IS OK. I WOULDN'T OKAY FOR HIM.
ARMS THAT WOULD BE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR TO SEE KATHERINE HAWKINS
MEMBER OF BOATING AND WATERWAYS
COMMISSION AS WELL AS ITEM D.
RUDOLPH RUDY MORELLO MEMBER
BOARD BOATING AND WATERWAYS
COMMISSION I WOULD MOVE THAT
SENATOR LARRY THANK YOU MOTION
HAS BEEN MADE SECRETARY WILL
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GROVE
HI GROVE I KAMLAGER HI I'M
LONGER I'D LAYERED BY WEIRD I
BATES. BATES AYE ATKINS FIVE
ATKINS AYE I WOULD CERTAINLY
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON ITEM
NUMBER THREE BILL REFERRALS.
SENATOR CALM WATER MOVES MADAM
SECRETARY. GROVE HI PROVIDE
KAMLAGER HI LONGER HIGH LAYERED
HI THERE I BATES RIGHT BATES
AYE ATKINS AYE ATKINS SIDE FIVE
ZERO THAT IS WONDERFUL SO NOW
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR AND WE WILL START
WITH ITEM ONE EIGHT AND THAT
WOULD BE THE APPOINTMENT OF
AMANDA EL REY IS COMMISSIONER
OF THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL. WELCOME COMMISSIONER
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU AND- I
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE I
WELCOME YOU TO INTRODUCE ANYONE
YOU WOULD LIKE THAT'S WITH YOU
MAKE YOUR OPENING COMMENTS
ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE
WITH US AND AFTER THAT I'LL GO
DIRECTLY TO MY COLLEAGUES.
WELCOME COMMISSIONER. THANK YOU
MA'AM AND I DON'T HAVE ANYONE
WITH ME TODAY BUT- I JUST LIKE
TO SAY GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MADAM VICE CHAIR SENATOR
KAMLAGER SENATOR LAYERED AND
CENTER GROVE. I WOULD LIKE TO
FIRST THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING
MY APPOINTMENT AS COMMISSIONER
OF CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL'S
IF NEEDED SIXTEEN COMMISSIONER
OF THIS WONDERFUL DEPARTMENT. I
WOULD FIRST LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
MY GUARDIAN ANGELS MY PARENTS
ALONG WITH MY SIBLINGS EXTENDED
FAMILY FRIENDS. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE YOUNG MAN I'M
FORTUNATE TO CALL MY SON KYLE.
THEIR LITTLE SUPPORT HAS BEEN
TRULY AMAZING. I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE A FEW MOMENTS TO TELL YOU
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT MYSELF MY
UPBRINGING AND HOW I GOT TO
WHERE I AM TODAY. THE REASON I
WANT TO START HERE IS BECAUSE
THIS STARTING POINT. IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME MY FAMILY. THE
OAKLAND COMMUNITY I GREW UP IN.
AND A DEDICATED WOMEN AND MEN
OF THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL. MY UPBRINGING HAS NOT
ONLY SHAPED MY VALUES AND
BELIEFS BUT IT ALSO PROVIDES ME
A UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
SERVICE EMPATHY AND
RELATIONSHIPS THE PUBLIC
EXPECTS. AND DESERVES OF ITS
LAW ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS.
BECAUSE OF WHERE I WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN BECAUSE I HAVE
COMMITTED THE LAST THIRTY ONE
YEARS OF MY LIFE. WORKING WITH
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES. I
KNOW WE NEED TO ENGAGE WITH ALL
THE COMMUNITIES WE SERVE
EQUALLY WITH RESPECT AND
DIGNITY AND TO EVALUATE
OURSELVES NOT ONLY FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF A PROFESSIONAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. BUT
FROM THE PUBLIC'S PERSPECTIVE
AS WELL. I HAVE LEARNED AND
CONTINUE TO IMPRESS ON ALL OF
THOSE THAT I WORK WITH. THAT WE
MUST LISTEN. TO THE COMMUNITIES
WE SERVE NOT JUST TO RESPOND
BUT TO UNDERSTAND. AS I'M SURE
WE WILL DISCUSS TODAY I HAVE
FOUR MAJOR GOALS AS THIS THE H.
P.'S NEW COMMISSIONER NUMBER
ONE IS TO REIMAGINE AND REBUILD
THE TRUST BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE COMMUNITIES
WE SERVE. NUMBER TWO IS TO
ESTABLISH A DIVERSITY H. P.
THAT IS MORE REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES WE
SERVE. NUMBER THREE IS TO
REDUCE DEMOLISH DEATH RATE AS
WELL AS INJURIES RELATED TO
VIOLENCE ON OUR ROADWAYS AND
FINALLY TO IMPROVE EMPLOYEE
HEALTH AND WELLNESS. BUT BEFORE
I TURN IT OVER TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS I LIKE BEING WITH
THIS. C. H. P. IS MADE UP OF
SOME OF THE MOST DEDICATED
WOMEN AND MEN. AND I AM SO
HONORED TO WORK ALONGSIDE EVERY
MEMBER OF THIS DEPARTMENT.
EVERY DAY. IT IS MY DEEP DESIRE
THAT WE AS THE LARGEST STATE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. IN THE
NATION. THAT WE ENDEAVOR
TOWARDS A MORE CONTEMPORARY
INNOVATIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY READY TO SERVE THE
PUBLIC. AND THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA DURING THESE HIGHLY
DYNAMIC TIMES. I LOOK FORWARD
TO THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT
TO BE TO BE ABLE TO PARTNER
WITH OUR DIVERSE COMMUNITIES TO
IMPROVE UNDERSTANDING A TRUSS.
I TRULY APPRECIATE I KNOW IT
TRANSPARENCY WHERE POSSIBLE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ARE TO
CORNERSTONES OF OUR SUCCESS
FURTHERMORE. THE CHP STANDS
READY TO COLLABORATE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AS WE MOVE FORWARD
ON THE PATH OF IMPROVEMENT FOR
TOMORROW. SO I FIRMLY BELIEVE.
EVERY CHALLENGE EVERY CHALLENGE
THAT I'VE HAD THROUGHOUT MY
LIFE EVERY TIME IT PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GROW. AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE INTROSPECTIVE
AND CLOSELY FOCUS ON HOW WE AS
PUBLIC SERVICE CAN BETTER SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. AND I
KNOW IT IS C. H. P. WILL NEED
YOURS AND THE PUBLIC'S
EXPECTATIONS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO MAKE THAT BRIEF
STATEMENT. AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU COMMISSIONER I
THINK I'M GOING TO GO FIRST OR
VICE CHAIRWOMAN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO GO FIRST SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU. ARE WE HAD A
WONDERFUL CONVERSATION
YESTERDAY IMAGE. HE MENTIONED I
THINK I'M PROBABLY SPEAKING FOR
EVERYONE WHO'S NOW QUITE AWARE
OF YOUR APPOINTMENT THAT WE ARE
ALL THRILLED TO SEE SOMEONE
COME FROM. YOU KNOW ENTRY LEVEL
RIGHT UP TO THE TOP POSITION
AND ESPECIALLY A WOMAN IF I
MIGHT- MENTIONED OUT TO BRIEFLY
AN IDEA WHEN WE WERE CHATTING
IN MY OFFICE PHí
CONGRADULATIONS WE SPOKE ABOUT
A NUMBER OF THE THINGS THAT
ARE- OF CONCERN ARE BETWEEN THE
PUBLIC OUR COMMUNITIES AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND I THINK YOUR
TOP PRIORITY THERE WHICH WE
SPOKE ABOUT IN DEPTH- THE TRUST
AND REBUILDING THAT BECAUSE
IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR.
CERTAINLY OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY AND OUR COMMUNITY AT
LARGE THAT SO WE UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU'RE THERE TO PROTECT
AND IN DOING THAT YOU ALSO HAVE
TO BE VERY RESPECTFUL AND
CAREFUL IN THE MANNER IN WHICH
YOU DO THAT PUBLIC SAFETY IS
THE HIGHEST PRIORITY OF
GOVERNMENT AND YOU'RE ON THE
FRONT LINE. ENSURING THAT THAT
DOES TAKE PLACE. IT WAS A WITH
A WONDERFUL. IDEA TO- MANSION
THE CONCERN I HAVEN'T LET ME
SHARE WITH MY COLLEAGUES VERY
QUICKLY. COMMISSIONER RAY- OUT
OF HER VERY BUSY SCHEDULE TOOK
A TRIP TO MY DISTRICT WHERE ONE
OF OUR- HIGHWAY PATROLMEN- WHO
WAS INJURED ON. AND TOOK TIME
OUT OF HER DAY TO GO DOWN VISIT
WITH- THE INDIVIDUAL WITH THE-
WITH THE HIGHWAY PATROL PERSON
AND ALSO WITH THE DISTRICT DOWN
THERE IN ASSURING THEM THAT SHE
IS ALWAYS ON CALL- TO INTERCEDE
OR BE PART OF- ANY- I THINK
BUILDING TRUST IN THE COMMUNITY
AND THIS WAS AN IMPORTANT ONE
SO I THINK THAT. IS BASICALLY
STANDS OUT AS A SIGNATURE OF
THIS WONDERFUL APPOINTMENT OF
COMMISSIONERATE TO THIS
POSITION. AND I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THAT ON THE
RECORD BECAUSE I HAD AN
INTERVIEW WITH. THE HIGHWAY
PATROL THAT VERY DAY ON THAT I
WAS GOING TO BE SPEAKING WITH A
COMMISSIONER AND TODAY'S- THEY
MENTIONED IT AND HOW. IT WAS
TODAY AND HOW. THEY WERE SO
IMPRESSED WITH THAT OUTREACH SO.
GOES WITHOUT SAYING ON YOUR
FIRST JOB IN MY DISTRICT HE GOT
AN A PLUS- THANK YOU AND I TO
YOU IF I THINK WE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE DO YOU AYE
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE. OF
ALCOHOL DRUGS AND IN PARTICULAR
THE OPIOIDS AND CANNABIS AND
HOW THAT IS- IT BECOME HAS
BECOME THE REAL SERIOUS ISSUE
IN TERMS OF THE WAY I TO ASSESS
HOW MANY OF THE IMPAIRED
DRIVING ACCIDENTS. ARE THE
RESULT OF- I THINK THE
INTRODUCTION OF THE OPIOID
ISSUE AND CERTAINLY MARIJUANA
BECAUSE SO COULD YOU SPEAK UP
SPECIFICALLY TO. HOW YOU'RE
DEALING WITH THAT CURRENTLY THE
COLLECTION OF DATA AND I
BELIEVE. THE IMPAIRED DRIVING
TASK FORCE REPORT. I HAVE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS IN AT- ON HOW
TO PURSUE IN TERMS OF DATA DATA
COLLECTION. SO COMMISSIONERATE
ON COULD YOU SHARE WITH US FOR
SOME OF YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT
BECAUSE IT HAS BECOME I THINK A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE. ARE
CERTAINLY AS WE'VE SEEN THE
INCREASE. IN THE USE OF DRUGS
AND MORE DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE
WHEN YOU DO OUR PULL SOMEONE
OVER. I GUESS MEDICAL CHAIR IN.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION.
AND HAS WE SPOKE ON YESTERDAY
AND I WERE JUST STTE AGAIN FOR
THE RECORD YOU KNOW ALCOHOL ND
DRUG IMPAIRED DRIVING IT
CONTINUES TO BE. A LEADING
CAUSE OF TRAFFIC FATALITIES AND
INJURIES IN CALIFORNIA. AND AT
THE HIGHWAY PATROL IS
DESIGNATED AS- AS CALIFORNIA'S
STATEWIDE DRUG RECOGNITION
EXPERT COORDINATOR AND THAT'S A
STATE WIDE DESIGNATION AND
WE'RE ALSO NATIONALLY KNOWN IN
THAT RESPECT. AND SO WE TRAIN
NOT ONLY JUST CHP OFFICERS BUT
OFFICE ALSO R. L. AGENCY
PARTNERS. AND BOTH THE DRUG
RECOGNITION EXPERT COURSES AND
ALL THE ADVANCED ROADSIDE
IMPAIRED DRIVING ENFORCEMENT
COURSE SO- TO DATE WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY FOURTEEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY CERTIFIED DAIRIES IN
CALIFORNIA. IN THE C. H. P.
ALONE HAS APPROXIMATELY SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY B. R. EASE.
SO ANOTHER THING- FOLLOWING THE
LEGISLATION OF THE LEGALIZATION
OF CANNABIS. OUR DEPARTMENT
BEGAN CAPTURING SPECIFIC DRUG
CATEGORY INFORMATION FROM
CRASHES INVESTIGATED BY THE CHP
AND WHICH TO DRIVER WAS
SUSPECTED OF BEING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE OF DRUGS. AND SO IN
TWENTY TWENTY R. CHP OFFICERS
SUSPECTED CANNABIS INVOLVEMENT
AS SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
CRASHES OCCURRING JUSTIN SEEMS
BE JURISDICTIONS. SO HOWEVER
THE CHALLENGES WE SPOKE ABOUT
YESTERDAY THERE CHALLENGES TO
TRACKING THE U. I. DRUG RELATED
ACCIDENTS AND D. U. I. DRUG
RELATED INCIDENTS- CURRENTLY IS
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND THE
FULL IMPACT OF CANNABIS
LEGALIZATION. AND HOW IT'S
AFFECTED OUR CANNABIS IMPAIRED
DRIVING INCIDENTS. BECAUSE
ALTHOUGH THE VEHICLE DOES
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN ALCOHOL DUI
AND DRUG IMPAIRED THE U. I. THE
VEHICLE CODE DOES NOT IDENTIFY
SPECIFIC DRUG CATEGORIES SUCH
AS CANNABIS OPIOIDS AS YOU
SPOKE OF EARLIER BY SUB
SECTION. SO AS SUCH THE
INCIDENCE OF DRUG IMPAIRED
DRIVING ARRESTS BY SPECIFIC
DRUGS. OR EVEN CATEGORIES IS
NOT TRACKED AND THE STATE LEVEL.
I KNOW CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE
THIS. WITH A KIND OF THIS
IMPAIRED. IT REMAINS THERE IS
NOT A SUB NO STANDARD- STATE OR
PRESENT LIMIT SUGGESTED POINT
ZERO EIGHT BLOOD ALCOHOL
CONCENTRATION THE MYTH THAT
EXIST WITH ALCOHOL INTOXICATION
SO FOR US- HER COMMITMENT TO
TRAFFIC SAFETY IN COMBAT A D.
U. I. REMAINS. DISEASE P. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO ADVANCE
RESEARCH IN THE AREA OF THE U.
I. DRUGS TO INCLUDE MEDICINE
EVALUATING THE PARAMEDIC. THE
CHP WE'RE ALSO MAKING A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN THE
FORENSIC TOXICOLOGY TESTING- I
KIND OF THIS TAX BRACKET PHONE
PROGRAM THAT WE SPOKE ABOUT AS
WELL. AND SO FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE GRANT CYCLE WE WERE
WE WILL BE AWARDING GRANT FUNDS
TO PUBLIC CRIME LABORATORIES-
WHICH WILL PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
A NEW EQUIPMENT TO IMPROVE
CALIFORNIA'S TESTING
CAPABILITIES. AND TO FACILITATE
THEIR RESEARCH I COULD IN THE
CANNABIS IMPAIRED DRIVING
STUDIES EFFORTS SO WE UP AND TO
BE ABLE TO COME UP WITH SOME
TYPE OF FLUID DRUG SCREENING
DEVICES. WE PARTNERING WITH THE
ACADEMIC RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS
SUCH AS UC SAN DIEGO CENTER FOR
MEDICAL CANNABIS RESEARCH UCLA
AND A DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES- RESEARCH AND-
DEVELOPMENT BRANCH SO SOME OF
THE INFORMATION HI THIS IS THIS
IS I KNOW IT'S COVERED IN OUR-
DRIVING. TASK FORCE REPORT THAT
YOU SPOKE ABOUT THAT WE
SUBMITTED TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND THAT WE JUST RELEASED IN
MARCH SO S. AND CSP'S
EXCAVATION- I AM FULLY
COMMITTED TO BRING STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER TO EXAMINE D. Y.
ISSUES. IN ORDER TO
STRATEGICALLY ALLOCATE
RESOURCES AND ENSURE THE
HIGHEST LEVEL ROADWAY SAFETY
FOR ALL THE CALIFORNIA
MOTORISTS AND S. D. YOU I DRUGS.
ANDY WHY ALCOHOL. THANK YOU CAN
SURE I THINK THAT CERTAINLY
COVERED IT VERY AND YOU THIRD
PRO. TO REDUCE THE DEATH RATE
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT MANY OF
THE ACCIDENTS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED WHEN THERE'S BEEN A DO
YOU ARE YOU INVOLVED JOB.
TRAGICALLY HAVE TAKEN LIVES SO
THAT IS WONDERFUL TO HEAR AND
CERTAINLY YOU WILL HAVE. MY
SUPPORT AND I'M SURE THEY ARE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORTED SHE MOVED
FORWARD AND START TO GET THAT
THAT FIND TO BE CONFIDENCE
BECAUSE IT NEEDS TO BE SIGNED
SPACE FOR SURE. IN TERMS OF HOW
YOU DETERMINE SOMEONE IS IN
FACT IMPAIR. THAT BASICALLY
COVERS ALL ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
I WANTED T RETURN TO THAT WE
HAD A GOOD DISCUSSION ON. SO
I'M GOING TO PASS UP THE
MICROPHONE TO. WHOEVER'S NEXT
AGAIN YOU SO MUCH FOR. YOUR
LONG TIME COMMITMENT TO THIS
VERY VERY IMPORTANT. ASSIGNMENT
AND IT IS TRULY PUBLIC SERVICE
AND YOU ARE CERTAINLY OFF.
STAND OUT IS A- INCREDIBLE
PUBLIC SERVANTS AND WISH YOU
THE VERY BEST AS YOU GO FORWARD
AND NOW SO WONDERFUL.
ASSIGNMENT YOU HAVE. AND A LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING MORE
INTERACTION WITH YOU I'M A
MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU. SHE DECLINED WORDS.
THE ONLY WAY THAT IF I SEE YOU
COMING AND I'M DRIVING I WOULD
BE VERY VERY CAREFUL. I
APPRECIATE THAT AS WELL. THANK
YOU. SENATOR BATES THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYER. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN AND COMMISSIONER THANK
SENATOR BATES WAS SPEAKING FOR
ALL OF US IF ANY OF ISSUE
DRIVING. UP BY WHERE WE ARE I'M
FIVE WANTED TO MAKE ONE COMMENT
AND I KNOW. S. AS IN ELECTED
OFFICIAL ARE YOU CANNOT RESIST
THINGS THAT ARE GRATUITOUS. BY
YOUR APPOINTMENT TRIGGERED ONE
OF MY BILLS AND IF YOU LOOK AT
THE CODE SECTION FOR
COMMISSIONER OF THE HIGHWAY
PATROL ALL THE REFERENCES ARE
TO HE AND HIM. AND SO I HAVE A
BILL IN AND EVERYBODY HERE
VOTED FOR LAST WEEK ON CONSENT
THAT BASICALLY. A CHANGES THOSE
REFERENCES TO MATCH WHO YOU ARE
NOW AND I'M PLEASED. FOR YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND THAT YOU
TRIGGERED THAT IT NOW AS AN
ASIDE EVERYBODY'S JUMPING ON
THE BANDWAGON SOME FIREFIGHTERS
HAVE GOTTEN CONSERVATION CORPS
TALK TO GENERAL BALDWIN TODAY
HE THINKS MAYBE THEY'RE
NATIONAL GUARD THINGS THAT NEED
TO BE ADDED SO. ARM ONCE AGAIN
YOU HAVE BEEN A LEADER. FIVE
TWO ENJOYED OUR TALK EARLIER
THIS WEEK AND I KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS WE TALKED ABOUT THE
STATE YOU HAD DONE SOME WORK.
FIVE YEARS AGO BEFORE YOU
APPOINTED COMMISSIONER ON THE
PUBLIC. TRUST MEASURE- YOUR
PUBLIC TRUST INITIATIVE AND-
NOW YOU'RE IN CHARGE SO WHAT
DID YOU LEARN FROM THAT A AND
WHAT DID IT MAKE YOU. WANT TO
ACT ON NOW THAT YOU'RE THERE.
THANK YOU CENTER AND I ALSO
THANK YOU FOR THAT- BILL I
THAT'S VERY INTUITIVE AND I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOU-
CONSIDERING MY TITLE IN THE
MAIL IS VERY NICELY- I TELL YOU
I THINK WE ALL KNOW THESE ARE
UNDOUBTEDLY CHALLENGING TIMES
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITIES- HOWEVER TRULY
BELIEVE IT IS A WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER IF THESE ARE ALSO
INSPIRING TIMES FOR TRUE
LEADERS IN THIS PROFESSION. SO
AS SUCH YOU KNOW I AM EXCITED
ABOUT THIS OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE
I HAVE A TEAM OF VERY TALENTED
LEADERS THAT UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE TASK OF IT.
IN A TASK THAT WE HAVE AHEAD OF
US I YOU SPOKE ABOUT THE-
PUBLIC TRUST INITIATIVE AND
THAT WAS ONE OF MY FOUR MAIN
GOALS IS TO REIMAGINE AND TO
INVIGORATE THE CHP'S PUBLIC
TRUST INITIATIVE. THE FED THE
INITIAL PUBLIC TRUST INITIATIVE
OF WHICH I WAS A MEMBER OF THE
TRAINING TEAM- IT WAS BEGAN IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN WE ESTABLISH THAT
INITIATIVE AND IT HAD THREE-
UNDERLYING PRINCIPLES ONE WAS.
YOU KNOW WAS THAT WE WANTED TO
BE ABLE TO- INTERACT WITH OUR
PUBLIC FROM A DIFFERENT
STANDPOINT AND ONE OF THEM WAS
THAT WE WOULD USE RESPECT AND
DIGNITY AND THAT WE WOULD
INTERACT WITH THE PUBLIC FROM A
PLACE WHERE EVERYTHING. FROM
INTEGRITY WHERE WE WOULD LOOK
AT IT NOT JUST FROM THE WAY WE
SEE THE PUBLIC BUT FOR THE WAY
THEY SEE US AND THEN ALSO THAT
AS AN APARTMENT WE WOULD CREATE
A UNIFIED VISION. TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYONE WAS INTERACTING
WITH THE PUBLIC IN THE SAME
MANNER AND I COULD TELL YOU-
AND FOR US THE OVERLYING PART
OF THAT IS IF WE HAVE THESE-RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE PUBLIC.
IT WOULD HELP US TO ESTABLISH A
DEPARTMENT THAT IS
REPRESENTATIVE OF CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES AND. I AM
FULLY COMMITTED IT. THE
EXAMINEE AWARENESS OF. RESEARCH
OUR IMPROVE HIRING PRACTICE. TO
BE ABLE TO. MOVE TOWARDS THAT
END- FURTHER THAN WHERE WE ARE
NOW. AND ALSO I'M FULLY
DEDICATED TO FOCUSING ON OUR
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS. ON
ATTRACTING QUALIFIED CANDIDATES
OF ALL DEMOGRAPHICS AND
GENDERS. WHILE PASSIVELY
SEEKING DEMING SEEKING OUT NEW
WAYS TO REACH ALL MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITIES WE SERVE. SO
THAT PUBLIC TRUST INITIATIVE.
IN THE END I WAS THE A BIG PART
OF WHAT IS WHICH IS DESIGNED TO
DO. WAS REALLY JUST TO HELP THE
HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO INCREASE OUR
FOOTPRINT IN THE COMMUNITIES WE
SERVE. BECAUSE ONE OF THE
THINGS WE KNOW THAT AND- THE
WORLD RELATIONSHIPS YOU KNOW
WE'VE MEET WHERE WE HAVE.
RELATIONSHIPS IN THE COMMUNITY
KNOWS US AND THEY KNOW THAT WE
ARE THEIR HIGHWAY PATROL. AND
THAT IS THE WAY THAT WE KNOW
THAT THAT WOULD MAKE PEOPLE
WANT TO BECOME A PART OF OUR
TEAM. AND THEN ALSO FOR THE
COMMUNITY TO BE THE FEEL SAFE
KNOWING THAT WE ARE OUT THERE.
TO TAKE CARE OF THEM AND MAKING
SURE THAT CALIFORNIA IS A SAFE
PLACE. TO LIVE WORK IN TRAVEL.
WITH A YOU YOU KNOW MY MEXICO.
WAS GOING TO BE ABOUT
RECRUITMENT AND YOU WRAP THAT
IN QUITE NICELY SO THANK YOU
AND THEN AND THE LAST THING. I
THOUGHT I WOULD ASK ABOUT IS.
AND I THINK UNTIL I WAS
SECRETARY FOR RESOURCES I NEVER
UNDERSTOOD THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL'S OF ROLE IN
EMERGENCY RESPONSE ED AND- YOU
WERE NICK WILL PARTNER. WITH
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES CAL FIRE OF THE
NATIONAL GUARD. OF THE FOUR
LEADERS WERE OUT FRONT ALL THE
TIME. END OF IT SEEMS LIKE. AS
WE HEAD INTO MORE FIRE INTO A-
PROJECT WE HAD SOME THINGS
AROUND THE CAPITAL EARLIER THIS
YEAR. EMERGENCY RESPONSE IS A
KEY PART OF YOUR POSITION- HOW
DO YOU VIEW THAT HOW DO YOU
PLAN FOR THIS IT IN YOUR ROLES
COMMISSIONER. I THINK THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT THROUGHOUT MY
THIRTY ONE YEARS WE'VE
CONTINUED TO GROW AS A
DEPARTMENT THAT THE MISSION OF
THE HIGHWAY PATROL- IS TO
PROVIDE THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
SAFETY SERVICE AND SECURITY SO
THAT SAYS A LOT IN ITSELF. IN
THIS INCLUDES NOT ONLY
PATROLLING STATE AND COUNTY ON
ROADWAYS ARE PROTECTING STATE
PROPERTY AND INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDING THE STATE CAPITAL SO
AS A STATEWIDE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY WE'RE COMMITTED TO
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC. AND THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS FOR
PEOPLE TO ASSEMBLE PROTEST IN A
LEGAL MANNER BUT SO TO THAT END
I WOULD TELL YOU THAT- THAT FOR
US- WE LOOK AT THAT FROM THE
BEST PLACES TO ENSURE PERSONAL
PROFESSIONAL. DEDICATED AND
HIGHLY TRAINED TO SAFEGUARD THE
PUBLIC ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
OTHER STATE EMPLOYEES AND THAT
INCLUDES A FAIR AND FIERSTEIN'S
AND BILL SAYING WE ARE OUR
RESPONSE IS NOT LIKE I STATED
EARLIER IS NOT JUST TO. PROTEST
BUT ALSO HELPING OUR ALLIED
AGENCY PARTNERS WHICH INCLUDE
CAL FIRE AND OTHER TRAFFIC
STAKEHOLDERS AND CAL FIRE AND-
IS A BIG PART OF THAT AND THEN
WE- ARE VERY FORTUNATE AND HAVE
A GREAT WORKING RELATIONSHIP TO
BE ABLE TO GO OUT AND- IN HELP
KEEP CALIFORNIA SAFE DURING
FIRE SEASON. AS WE KNOW THAT'S
A BEING ALWAYS WE'RE HERE AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
ACTUALLY GET A COUPLE PRESS
CONFERENCES TOGETHER NOW WHAT
IS BEING DONE TODAY BY ONE OF
MY SYSTEM COMMISSIONERS AND
STANDING IN FOR ME. TO CONDUCT
A PRESS CONFERENCE BASICALLY
JUST MAKING CALIFORNIA WHERE
THAT WE ARE IN FIRE SEASON SO
PLEASE BE CAREFUL WHICH
THROWING A LIT I HAVE SIX I
LIKE CIGARETTES OUT OF CAR
WINDOWS IN THE BRUSH AND JUST
BEING VERY CAREFUL THAT WE-
DON'T USE- CARELESSNESS AND
MAKE CARELESS. MISTAKES THAT
BILL ACTUALLY EXACERBATE THAT
FIRE SEASON. IN THE SITUATION
THAT WILL BE GOING INTO. THANK
YOU A YOU MAY. I'M REALLY TO BE.
TO YOU WHEN WE GET TO. THANK
YOU SIR I THAT STAFF. THANK
SENATOR LAYERED- SENATOR GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEN NM.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO VISIT WITH
YOU AGAIN- COMMISSIONERATE WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO TALK
TO YOU AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE TIME THAT YOU GAVE ME
YESTERDAY- I LEARNED A LOT IN
AND I WAS VERY PLEASED WITH ALL
THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU ANSWERED
FOR ME YESTERDAY. AS MY
COLLEAGUE AND SENATOR LAYERED
ASKED TO THE QUESTIONS I WAS
GONNA ASK AND MISS BATES
COVERED THE CANNABIS AND
ALCOHOL ISSUE ON THAT THE
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE SO
I'LL GO BACK TO. THE SWING
SPACE- AS WE DISCUSSED
YESTERDAY YOU KNOW THAT ALL OF
US ARE GOING TO BE MOVING INTO
THE SWING SPACE I BELIEVE IN
OCTOBER RIGHT AFTER SESSION M.
IS OVER AND SO- SAME QUESTION I
ASKED YOU YESTERDAY- IS IT
YOUR- ANTICIPATION OR YOUR-
UNDERSTANDING OR DIRECTION
THAT. WE WILL BE COVERED BY C.
H. P. THAT PROTECTION AT THE
SWING SPACE AS WELL- YES MA'AM
WE ARE FULLY PREPARED AND HAVE
BEEN- WORKING TOWARDS AN END TO
BE ABLE TO AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN PROVIDE. PROTECTION AT
THE SWING SPACE AS WELL AS AS
THE CAPITAL I'M WHILE BACK NEW
ANNEXES BEING BUILT SO YES
WE'VE BEEN A PART OF THE
PLANNING SESSIONS AND A PART
OF- THAT LOOKING AT THE- CYCLE
ABILITY AND CONDUCTING THOSE
ASSESSMENTS SO THAT WE CAN SEE
IF THERE IS ANY TYPE OF ISSUES
AND THINGS THAT WE CN SEE FROM
OUR STANDPOINT- FROM A PUBLIC
SAFETY STANDPOINT THAT WE CAN
MAKE SUGGESTIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE. TO CONSIDER DURING
THE- DEVELOPMENT IN IT OF THAT
ACTUAL SWING SPACE SO YES NO
WE'RE HONORED TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THAT PROTECTION. TO ALL
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE MEMBERS.
OF THE CAPITAL OF PEOPLE THAT
WORK THERE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MA'AM CAN
WE ALSO TALK A LITTLE BIT
YESTERDAY ABOUT AND- THE RIGHTS
AND THINGS THAT HAPPENED- LAST
SUMMER AND- I SHARED WITH YOU
THAT WHEN I CAME OUT OF THE
BASEMENT THERE WAS A CHP
OFFICER BEING BROUGHT BACK IN
WITH TWO OF HIS BUDDIES AND
HE'S WALKING ON HIS OWN TWO
FEET BUT- THEY'RE BOTH NEXT TO
HIM AND HIS HEAD WAS BLEEDING
HE WAS HIT IN THE HEAD WITH A
BOTTLE. OF WATER A LOT ABOUT IT
WAS STILL THE SAME IT. AND
WHAT'S YOUR PLAN. IS THE
HIGHEST RANKING. YOU KNOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT CHP OFFICER IN THE
ENTIRE STATE. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT THOSE MEN AND WOMEN THAT
DO THIS PUBLIC SERVICE AND
PROVIDE. SAFETY AND SECURITY
FOR OUR COMMUNITY I'M HAPPY
WITH THE RISING. ISSUES GOING
ON BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
THE COMMUNITY HOW ARE WE GOING
TO KEEP LAW ENFORCEMENT. SAFE
WELL I TELL YOU I THINK WITH-
WHEN IT COMES TO KEEPING A
STATE. IT IS ALWAYS GOING TO GO
BACK TO TRAINING HAVING A
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES THAT
WILL MAKE SURE THAT OUR PEOPLE
ARE WELL TRAINED AND THAT
EVERYTHING THAT WE'RE DOING IS
WITHIN THE LAW AND WITH THE
POLICY SO THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE. POSTURED TO BE
ABLE TO PROTECT. OUR CITIZENS
RIGHT TO OUR THEIR FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT TO PROTEST
PEACEFULLY BUT ALSO TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN KEEP OUR SALES
AND SERVICE AND SAFE WHILE
THEY'RE DOING SO- SO WHAT I
THINK I TELL YOU WHAT WE DO IS
WE- WE REGULARLY ASSESS. OUR
CIVIL DISTURBANCE OPERATIONAL
PLANS TO ENSURE DEPARTMENTAL
PERSONNEL ARE INFORMED AND
EQUIPPED TO RESPOND TO
EMERGENCY EVENTS. AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY WE CONSTANTLY
STRESS PREPARATION TO ADJUST
OUR OPERATIONAL POSTURE AS THE
PARSER OSTER IN EXCESS OF THE
PROTESTERS CHANGE BECAUSE
DURING THAT TIME I THINK WE
SPOKE ABOUT SOME OF IT AS YOU
STATED JUST NOW. WE'VE
EXPERIENCED A LOT WITH THAT THE
LAST THING WE HAD PEOPLE CLIMB
OVER BARRIER WE HAD- BOTTLES
BRICKS ROCKS- KIND OF PAINS-
BETTER BAND- TOSSED AWAY AND
THROWN. ONE OF THEM A WHICH YOU
SAW WHICH HASN'T HAPPENED THERE
AT THE CAPITOL. BUT ONE OF
THINGS WE ALSO EXPERIENCE LIKE
I TALKED ABOUT YESTERDAY IT'S
BEEN AN UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER
PROTESTS- THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED AND- THAT HAVE
ENCOURAGE JUST READ GOT TO
REEVALUATE OUR CIVIL
DISTURBANCE TRAINING. SO ONE OF
THE THINGS IS THIS WEEK'S
WEAVER STRATEGICALLY PIVOTED TO
FOCUS ON ARE CLICKABLE LOS OUR
DEPLOYMENT STRATEGIES AND DE
ESCALATION TECHNIQUES SO- I SEE
IT IS. FROM MY STANDPOINT AS US
TAKING A MORE COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO TRAINING TO MAKE
SURE OUR PERSONNEL ARE HIGHLY
CHINESE BUILDING PROFESSIONAL.
BECAUSE ONE OF THE THINGS- I
WOULD TELL YOU- AS I THINK IS
PROBABLY THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING THAT WE LEARNED AND THAT
WE- CHANGING. IS THAT WE AVAIL
OURSELVES OF EVERY OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE POSITIVE INTERACTIONS
WITH THE COMMUNITIES WE. SERVE
A LOT OF FORCED ME TO PASS THE
THAT WAS- ALSO VERY- AND
THEY'LL ALSO VERY OF. MOMENT
THAT WE HAVE. WELL WE'RE OVER
AT THE- I'M DOING SOME OF THOSE
FROM. AND MASS. AND SO I'VE
LIKE WE- TO STEP INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES ALLOW FOR
MEANINGFUL CONVERSATIONS. IN
WHICH TO SEE HPC AS- A
RESPONSIBLE AMOUNT OF TIME
LISTENING TO OUR COMMUNITY.
CONCERNS AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
JUST INCREASING OUR
ACCESSIBILITY SO THAT OUR
COMMUNITY THING IN OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS KNOW. WHO WE
ARE WHAT WE DO. AND WHAT
DEPARTMENT OR SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
THEM AND LITERALLY I REALLY
FEEL LIKE- WHEN WE WENT OUT
THERE WE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK WITH THE PROTESTERS. THAT
THAT WAS A VALUABLE DURING A
PROTEST IN SUMMER I MEAN ONE OF
THE THINGS WE LEARN. WE LEARN
WHAT WAS IMPORTANT TO THEM. AND
SOMETIMES JUST THAT SIMPLE
CONVERSATION EASE TENSIONS IT
PROVIDED PARAMETERS AND WE WERE
ABLE TO GET PARAMETERS AND HAVE
UNDERSTANDING. WITH SOME OF
THOSE PROTESTERS THEY WE WERE
ABLE TO USE THROUGHOUT THE
SUMMER SO AGAIN I TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER A LOT OF THAT IS-
RELATIONSHIPS. BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS FROM AN EMPLOYEE
STANDPOINT. WAS WHILE WE WERE
COMMITTED YOU KNOW. TO HAVING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS TO ENHANCE
TRUST WITH OUR COMMUNITIES YOU
KNOW WE ALSO KNOW WE HAVE TO
PRIORITIZE THE WELL BEING OF
OUR- OUR DEDICATED WOMEN AND
MEN THAT ARE OUT THERE. YOU
KNOW YOU KNOW LAST SUMMER YOU
KNOW WHEN WE'RE ON TACTICAL
ALERT WORLD TWELVE ARE RECEIVED
AND WE WERE DOING THOSE THINGS.
WE WERE CONSTANTLY MONITORING
ARE PLEADING WELLNESS AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO DEVELOP
AND SUSTAIN A HIGHLY COMPETENT.
PROFESSIONAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU MA'AM
THANK VERY MUCH. I AM WORKING
VERY APOLOGY I AM. I DO WANT TO
SAY THAT THERE IS A LOT OF
MEDIA ATTENTION ABOUT YOU BEING
THE FIRST WOMAN APPOINTED AND
TO THIS POSITION AND I'M
HONORED I MEAN I THINK THAT'S
PRETTY AMAZING I'M THE FIRST
FEMALE VETERAN THAT'S EVER
SERVED IN THIS CAPITAL. AND I
WEAR THAT BADGE WITH PRIDE AND
YOU BEING THE FIRST WOMAN
COMMISSIONER THE CALIFORNIA
STATE HIGHWAY PATROL. BUT I CAN
TELL YOU THAT- AND YOU'RE IN
THAT POSITION BECAUSE YOU'RE
QUALIFIED. AND I'M I'M GLAD
YOU'RE A WOMAN BUT YOU ARE IN
THAT POSITION BECAUSE YOU'RE
QUALIFIED AND NOT BECAUSE
YOU'RE A WOMAN SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR CONFIRMATION. YOU VERY
MUCH MA'AM I APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU GRADUATION TO YOU TOO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
GROVE- SENATOR COM LONGER
YOU'RE RIGHT ON TIME I DO IN
MULTI COMMITTEES- WELCOME BACK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. AND IT'S
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN
COMMISSIONER I TOO ENJOYED- OUR
CONVERSATION AND- EAGERLY AWAIT
THIS DISCUSSION AE IN AS WELL
AS SEEING YOU CONFIRMED- AS WE
DISCUSSED AND I KNOW THERE'S SO
MANY OF US THAT ARE- VERY
EXCITED THAT YOU WILL BE
SERVING IN THIS POSITION. I
THINK I WANT TO ECHO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE SAID THAT IF I SEE
YOU COMING WHILE I'M TEMPTED TO
PROBABLY GO FASTER I WILL SLOW
DOWN. RIGHT TO OBEY THE LAW-
VERY HAPPY TO- HERE YOU STATE
YOUR- FOR PRIORITIES- AND IT'S
ALWAYS- IT'S IMPORTANT I THINK
IT IS IMPORTANT TO HEAR FOLKS
TALK ABOUT THE STAFF THAT-
SERVE IN THESE DEPARTMENTS-
BECAUSE IT IS ABOUT OUR HUMAN
CAPITAL THAT WE WANT TO
SUPPORT- AND THAT WE WANT TO
EMPOWER AND SO RECRUITMENT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND THEN
HEALTH AND WELLNESS OF OUR
EMPLOYEES IS EQUALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE- WELL REPRESENTATION IS
IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF
DIVERSITY. YOU ALSO WANT FOLKS
THAT ARE HAPPY DOING WHAT
THEY'RE DOING AND FEELING AS IF
THEY ARE SUPPORTED- AND SO WE
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THIS
SO I AND I DID SHARE WITH YOU
THAT I WAS GOING TO ASK IT-
DURING TODAY. AROUND DIVERSITY
IN RECRUITMENT AND MAKING SURE
THAT YOU HAVE A MORE
REPRESENTATIVE WORKFORCE HOW
IMPORTANT THAT IS- IT WAS NOTED
THAT- THERE WERE A NUMBER OF.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE OF COLOR. WHO
SORT OF FAILED OUT I THINK
DURING WEAPONS TRAINING. NO NO
DURING THE DRIVING EXAMS BUT
THEN THE WOMEN TENDED TO FAIL
OUT DURING THE WEAPONS EXAMS
AND IT WAS ALSO NOTED- IN THE
READING THAT THE FAIL RATE HAS
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY SO THERE
HAS BEEN SOME WORK DONE TO IT-
REALLY ADDRESS- THE ATTRITION
RATES AND I WAS WANTING IF YOU
COULD JUST SPEAK TO. WHAT
CHANGED OUR THAT ALLOWED YOU
ALL TO SEE A CHANGE IN THAT
TREND. FROM THANK YOU MA'AM YES
HI I TELL YOU ONE OF THE THINGS
LIKE I STATED EARLIER WAS-
BEING ABLE TO COME UP THROUGH
THE RANKS GAVE ME AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A LOOK. AT
SOME OF OUR PROCESSES
PROCEDURES AND THAT GOES ALL
THE WAY FROM THE KING AT OUR
ACADEMY AND LOOKING AT WAYS
THAT WE CAN HELP MAKE THIS TO
BE MORE SUCCESSFUL WHETHER
THEY'RE AT THE ACADEMY AND WE
LOOK AT OUR TRADITION RATE. AND
ACADEMY AND WE HAD A LOT OF OUR
AND WE SAW THAT WE HAD ABOUT
ABOUT A 40% OR 30% DEPEND ON
WHAT THE WHICH CLASS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A REFERENCE
STATE. THAT WE WERE HAVING THAT
TYPE OF THE SITUATION AND ARE
DRIVING AND OUR- WEAPONS
TRAINING AS YOU STATED EARLIER
WE TAKE A LOOK AT THAT AND WE
TOOK A HARD LOOK AT IT AND ONE
OF THINGS THAT WE WOULD LOOK AT
IT WHEN WE- TALK ABOUT OUR OUR
DRIVING WHICH WE- WE CALL OUR
EVE UP COURSES. WE WERE ABLE TO
TAKE A SEAT AND WE WERE OURS
ARE ARE VERY STANDARDS HAVE FAR
EXCEEDED. WHAT THE POLL
STANDARDS WERE FOR OUR DRIVING
BUT ALSO WE LOOKED AT IT AND
SAID YOU KNOW HOW CAN WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH MORE TRAINING
SAID MAYBE WE CAN YOU KNOW HELP
SOME OF THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
HAVING A HARD TIME. NAVIGATING
THAT COURSE AND THAT'S JUST
WHAT WE DID YOU KNOW WITH A
TRAINING OF THE CADETS
VOLUNTEERED TO COME IN AFTER
HOURS WHENEVER THEY DIDN'T. AND
WE PROVIDED ADDITIONAL TRAINING
AND YOU KNOW AND IT'S IT WAS
PRETTY IF YOU LOOK AT IT JUST
FROM THAT STANDPOINT I THINK
MOST FOR MOST PEOPLE THE MORE
YOU DO SOMETHING THE BETTER YOU
GONNA GET AT IT AND- AND THEY
DID THAT AND WE WERE ABLE TO. I
MEAN DISINTEREST SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASING- DECREASE THAT
FAILURE RATE AND NOW I'M J. U.
THAT WE'RE DOWN TO THE SIX
SIMILAR KIND OF DUMPING THAT WE
DID WITH THE- WITH THE SHOOTING
AND WE'RE DOWN TO I BELIEVE HAD
ATTRITION RATES IN THOSE TWO
CATEGORIES. THAT SOMETIME TO
BAN ADAM 0025% AND THEN 10% SO
IT'S BEEN A VERY IS VERY
BENEFICIAL FOR US AS A
DEPARTMENT BECAUSE CLEARLY. WE
PUT A LOT. OF A LOT OF WORK AND
EFFORT INTO RECRUITING HE
FOLLOWED. INTO AND WE GET THEM
TO THEY CAN WE- WANT TO PROVIDE
THEM WITH THE HIGH. QUALITY
TRAINING. HOPE IT TAKE A COME
OUT AND BE OF OUR TEAM. SO
WHATEVER CAN DO THE TO. THOSE
CHANGES WE WILL AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT DOING AND BEING
REFLECTIVE INTROSPECTIVE ACROSS
ALL ASPECTS OF THE ACADEMY. AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
STARTED WHEN I WAS- THE CHIEF
THE US- THERE WAS WORKING FOR
THE ASSISTANT COMMISSIONER WITH
THE SAP SITE. AND WE HADN'T
BEEN DOING THAT CONSISTENTLY.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT
MOVING FORWARD. GREAT THANK YOU
FOR THAT- I HAVE TO SAY WELL I
WAS. LISTENING TO YOU I NOTICED
THAT YOU ARE ON TREND BECAUSE
YOU HAVE A FIDDLE LEAF FG IN
THE BACKGROUND. SO HOPEFULLY
SOMEONE TECHNOLOGY IS THAT- YOU
KNOW WE ALSO TALKED A LOT
ABOUT- THE- MISCONDUCT SOME
MISCONDUCT THAT WAS- SORT OF
REVEALED IN A NUMBER OF
ARTICLES- EMPLOYEE MISCONDUCT
SOME SCANDALS I GUESS- WITH
SOME OFFICERS THERE WERE A
COUPLE OF ARTICLES AROUND
FRAUDULENT OVERTIME PAY I
DIDN'T GET THAT THE EAST LA
OFFICE BUT THEN ALSO SOME
INCIDENTS WHERE- WOMEN WERE-
HARASSED- I THINK BY ONE OR A
COUPLE OF- OFFICERS. AND THOSE
FOLKS I DO KNOW WERE-
DISCIPLINED APPROPRIATELY BUT
WANTED TO KNOW IF YOU COULD
SPEAK TO HOW YOU ARE- INSURING
THAT OFFICERS ARE CONDUCTING
THEMSELVES PROFESSIONALLY
BECAUSE ON THE ONE HAND WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT BUILDING TRUST IT'S-
THE INTERFACE THAT OFFICERS
HAVE YOU KNOW WHAT THE GENERAL
PUBLIC IN TERMS OF THE WORK
THAT THEY'RE DOING AND THEN ON
THE OTHER HAND IT'S ABOUT YOU
KNOW HOW FOLKS ARE BEING
TREATED- IN. YES ABSOLUTELY-
YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK IS TWO
FOLD I KNOW THAT- NUMBER ONE IS
HIS WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT OUR POLICY IS THE POLICY
OF THE HIGHWAY PATROL THE TREAT
EMPLOYEES AND THE PUBLIC MISTER
RESPECT AND FAIRNESS AND INSURE
ALL OF OUR PRACTICES ARE
ETHICAL AND EQUITABLE. AND
THESE ORGANIZATIONAL VALUES
THESE ARE THE FOUNDATION OF OUR
OF WHAT WE DO AND ALSO PART OF
THE CULTURE AWARENESS TRAINING
THAT WE PROVIDE TO ALL OF OUR
EMPLOYEES AND SO THAT TRAINING
PROVIDERS ARE SEEKING EMPLOYEES
WITH STRATEGIES FOR SUCCESSFUL
CONTACTS WITH INDIVIDUALS FROM
DIFFERENT CULTURES RACIAL OR
ETHNIC BACKGROUNDS AS WELL AS-
DETAILING THE IMPORTANCE OF
RECOGNIZING AND RESPECTING THE
COMPLEXITIES OF CULTURAL
DIVERSITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING ON OUR DEPARTMENT SO-
I BELIEVE THAT TRAINING-
REALLY- THIS IS GOING TO BE THE
BACKGROUND THE BACKBONE OF THAT
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO WITH
MISCONDUCT. ALSO THE PUBLIC
RIGHTFULLY EXPECTS ONLY THE
HIGHEST STANDARDS FROM OUR
EMPLOYEES AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
IT HAVE FAITH THAT THE CHP WILL
FULLY INVESTIGATE ANY
ALLEGATION OF MISCONDUCT AND A
THOROUGH OBJECTIVE AND TIMELY
MANNER AND MOREOVER LIKE WITH
US THE PUBLIC EXPECTS THAT IF
NECESSARY THAT WE WILL TAKE
APPROPRIATE ACTION TO SAFEGUARD
THE TRI STATE THAT WE HAVE
BUILT WITH OUR COMMUNITIES AND
I'LL TELL YOU AS A
COMMISSIONER. I CAN ASSURE YOU
WE WILL MEET THAT EXPECTATION
FOR ME OUR PROACTIVE APPROACH
FOR ENSURING ACCOUNTABILITY
STARTS WITH SOUND POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES AND COUPLED WITH ON
GOING TO SUSTAIN TRAINING AND
THAT TRAINING BEGINS AT THE
ACADEMY SO I EXPECT EVERY
MEMBER TO SEIZE PETRI THE
FELLOW EMPLOYEES AND THE PUBLIC
WE SERVE OR RESPECT AND
FAIRNESS AND INSURER PRACTICES.
ARE A ETHICAL AND EQUITABLE AND
THESE ARE THE ORGANIZATIONAL
VALUES THAT ARE THE FOUNDATION
FOR EVERYTHING THAT WE DO BUT I
TELL YOU THAT IF- IN THE END.
IF THERE IS SOMETHING ELSE THAT
I'M SHOWS THAT WE HAVE TO GO
GOOD FOR. WE ALSO- IN THE DAY
ASSIST. THAT WE HAVE ACCESS TO
THAT WE CAN USE IT WILL
ACTUALLY TELL US IF THERE'S ANY
TRENDS OR ANYTHING THAT WE NEED
TO LOOK AT. WHERE THERE IS A
WAY THAT WE ARE ABLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE MONITORING OUR
SALES AND MONITORING OUR WORK
SPACE INSURING. THAT THOSE
THINGS WILL HAPPEN BUT IF THEY
DO THEN YOU WILL YOU KNOW WE
WILL TAKE THE APPROPRIATE
ACTION AS YOU STATED EARLIER.
TO MAKE SURE THAT ANY OF THOSE
IF ANY DEFICIENCY ARE CONCERNS
IDENTIFY. THAT IS PROBABLY
ADDRESS THROUGH CONSTRUCTIVE
INTERVENTION STRATEGIES THAT
BASICALLY INCLUDES COUNSELING
TRAINING AND OUR OTHER PROGRAMS
AS A PRIMARY INTERVENTIONS-
BACK INCLUDE UP TO TERMINATION
IF NECESSARY. WELL I CAN JUST
WE ALSO TALKED ABOUT THIS THAT
YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE YOUR
RESPONSE AND- YOU KNOW SIX
YEARS AGO THERE WAS AN
INCIDENT- ON THE TEN FREEWAY-
BETWEEN A CHP OFFICER AND- AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMAN MARLENE
PANIC. THAT THE IT WAS CAPTURED
ON VIDEO IT WENT VIRAL AND I
CAN TELL YOU THAT THE RESPONSE
FROM CHP WAS SWIFT IMMEDIATELY
TALKING ABOUT ADDITIONAL
TRAINING THAT. OFFICERS NEEDED-
IN REALLY SORT OF MOVING FRONT
AND CENTER ISSUES AROUND MENTAL
ILLNESS AND WORKING WITH FOLKS
WHO ARE ON HOUSED IN HOW TO DO
THAT IN A WAY THAT WAS
APPROPRIATE- AND I WAS.
SURPRISED PLEASANTLY SURPRISED
WITH THE SERIOUSNESS WITH WHICH
THE H. P. TOOK THE INCIDENT-
AND THE STEPS THAT THEY- WORK
TO ENACT A RATHER QUICKLY. I
WITH REGARDS TO OUR RESPONSE ON
A GO FORWARD BASIS IN TERMS OF
TRAINING AND HELPING OFFICERS
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE OTHER
THAN-
BELIEVE WHAT YOU ARE SAYING
BECAUSE I HAVE SEEN IT- THANK
YOU FOR THIS TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE IT. THANK
YOU SENATOR- THE COMMISSIONER-
YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE VERY MUCH
THIS IS A CONFIRMATION- BUT I
HAVE TO SAY IT'S A THOROUGHLY
ENJOYABLE CONVERSATION AND
DIALOGUE- I JOIN MY COLLEAGUES.
IN THE APPRECIATION OF YOUR
LAYING OUT VERY QUICKLY AT THE
BEGINNING YOUR GOALS- I
PARTICULARLY YOU LOVE THE FACT
THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT RE
IMAGINING- LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
THIS DAY IN TIME AND HOW TO
HELP THE DEPARTMENT MOVE
FORWARD. IN A POSITIVE WAY FOR
BOTH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
COMMUNITY- THE DIVERSITY ISSUE
I AM IN MY FIFTH YEAR ON THE
RULES COMMITTEE. AND I REMEMBER
OF THE CONFIRMATION OF FORMER
COMMISSIONER WARREN STANLEY AND
TALKING ABOUT DIVERSITY AND
TALKING ABOUT THE- ISSUES
OUTLINED BY SENATOR COM LONGER
AROUND. THE VARIOUS CATEGORIES
AND WHY A KID IT'S WOULD DO
WELL IN SOME AREAS NOT OTHERS
AND TO LOOK AT THE PERCENTAGES
AND NUMBERS- REFLECTING. THE
MAKE UP COMPARED TO THE
STATEWIDE- POPULATION SO THE
FACT THAT YOU. OUTLINED THAT
DIVERSITY AND YOU'RE ABLE TO
TALK SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
QUESTIONS THAT I ASK IS A RULES
COMMITTEE MEN MEMBER UNDER THE
FORMER PRO TEM. ABOUT BOTH
DRIVING AND SHOOTING AND IT'S
EASY TO SEE AS THE CHIEF AN
ASSISTANT COMMISSIONER. BETWEEN
THEN AND NOW ALL THAT THERE'S
BEEN SOME WORK DONE IN THAT
AREA SO I TRULY APPRECIATE
THAT. AS WELL AS THE FOCUS ON
EMPLOYEE HEALTH AND WELLNESS
OUR- AND CERTAINLY REDUCING
DEATHS THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
VERY CLEAR. ABOUT THAT FOCUS-
YEAH REALLY AND IT REMINDS ME
OF ACTUALLY RUN INTO YOU IN THE
BASEMENT OF THE CAPITOL- AS WE
WERE BUT YOU WERE. MOVING TO
HIGH ALERT AROUND SECURITY IN
THE CAPITAL AND I JUST WANTED
TO SAY HELLO BUT YOU WERE ALL
BUSINESS YOU WERE ON TASK AND
YOU WERE HOT YOU HAD A MISSION
AND- I COULD TELL THAT. WE WERE
GOING TO BE WELL SERVED AND
JUST YOU'RE KEEPING US POSTED
AND THAT WAS RELATIVELY SOON
AFTER YOU WERE. APPOINTED IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY TWENTY IT
WASN'T THAT LONG AFTER. OUT WE
HAD TO DEAL WITH A NUMBER OF
THINGS SO. I CANNOT TELL YOU
HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE- YOUR
PROFESSIONALISM YOUR- YOUR
DEDICATION AND TO WHAT A
SENATOR GROVE SAID. YOUR
ABSOLUTE QUALIFICATIONS TO DO
THIS JOB. I- WANTED TO SAY ALSO
HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE
REPRESENTING SAN DIEGO I HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TOUR THE
PREVIOUS. CHP FACILITY- WHICH
WAS LACKING- SIGNIFICANTLY IN
TERMS OF SPACE AND AVAILABILITY
AND NEEDS FOR THE OFFICERS
THERE. TO THE NEW ONE WHICH IS
SO NICE. YOU KNOW TO REFLECT
THE FACT THAT WE ACTUALLY CARE
ABOUT OUR STAFF AND THEY
DESERVE A FACILITY. I KNOW
THAT. ARE REPLACING SOME OF
THOSE FACILITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE HAS A SLOW DOWN A BIT-
MAYBE WITH ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
AND ONE TIME FUNDS WE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO ASSIST IN THAT REGARD
JUST MY OWN THOUGHT- I KNOW
THAT MOST OF THE RESOURCES TO
FIND C. H. P. COME FROM- MOTOR
VEHICLE FEES. I UNDERSTAND THAT
BUT- WHEN WE CAN GET A HIT IT
WOULD BE GOOD TO PROVIDE
ADEQUATE SPACE FOR OUR OFFICERS
I DID WANT TO ASK A QUESTION-
IN TERMS OF. THE NUMBER OF
OFFICERS ARE. EMPLOYED YOU KNOW
I HAVE TO WONDER IF WE ACTUALLY
HAVE ENOUGH OFFICERS ARE SAN
DIEGO. I KNOW IT'S A BIG AREA I
THINK THAT THE COVERAGE AREA
FOR CHP THERE IS BROADER THAN
JUST SAN DIEGO COUNTY IT MIGHT
INCLUDE PARTS OF IMPERIAL IF
I'M CORRECT AND I JUST I KNOW
YOU ARE SLOTTED A BUDGET I KNOW
YOU ARE SLOTTED A NUMBER OF ARM.
SLIGHTS BUT- WONDERING IF YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE ADEQUATE
RESOURCES TO DO ALL THAT IS PUT
ON YOUR PLATE UP AND DOWN THE
STATE I IN THE HUNDRED AND
THREE KIND OF OFFICES AND
FACILITIES THAT YOU HAVE.
WELCOME MA'AM GREAT QUESTION
THERE WELL IT'S A IS- I THINK I
WOULD HAVE BIG BIG THE MOST OF
THE WORLD WE WERE HEAVILY
AFFECTED BY. COLGATE AND WITHIN
THAT THAT WITH OUR ACADEMY SO-
WHEN KOHLI HIT YOU KNOW I HAD
WAITED CLOSE DOWN ACADEMY THE
FIRST TIME UNDER COMMISSIONER
STANLEY AND THEN AGAIN UNDER-
WHEN I BECAME THE COMMISSIONER
SO THAT WAS TWO TIMES WE HAD TO
CLOSE IT DOWN AND THEN ALSO-
WHICH AFFECTED HER GRADUATION
RATE AND HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
REPLACE- THE REPLACE OFFICERS
AS OTHER PEOPLE RETIREE. THE
OTHER ISSUE THAT HAPPENED WHEN
WE HAD TO CLOSE IT DOWN THE
SECOND TIME WE WERE ABLE TO
OPEN IT- WE HAD OPENED IT
DIFFERENTLY WE HAD THAT WILL TO
HAVE A REINTEGRATION PLAN THAT
INCLUDED ONLY RUNNING ONE CLASS
AND REDUCING THE NUMBER OF THAT
CLASS SO THAT WE CAN PLAY GOOD
DEBTS IN THEIR OWN SEPARATE
SPACES. SO WE'VE YOU KNOW WE'VE
WE HAVE A PLAN TO THE YOU KNOW
THIS ONE CLASS IS GOING TO
GRADUATE IN JULY AND HOPEFULLY
WE WILL BE ABLE TO PUT MORE
BODIES IN THERE AND THAT PLANS
BEEN SUCCESSFUL SO FAR FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO- GET THIS CLASS
GRADUATED IN MAY. THEY'VE BEEN
ABLE TO STAY SAFE THROUGHOUT
THIS TIME SO WITH A LOT OF
DIFFERENT MEASURES WE PUT IN
PLACE SO HOPEFULLY AS WE
INCREASE THE NUMBERS OF THE
CLASSES AND GET BACK TO AND WE
GET- EVERYONE BEING ABLE TO GET
BACK AND RUNNING MULTIPLE
CLASSES BACK TO BACK WE WILL BE
ABLE TO. TAP INTO THOSE NUMBERS
AND GET OUR NUMBERS BACK UP TO
YOU KNOW WHERE WE WERE WE WERE
AND WHERE WE NEED TO BE AND
WHAT WE WOULD LIKE TO BE SO
THAT'S- YOU KNOW SO I'M I'M
VERY VERY- HOPEFUL THEY WILL BE
ABLE TO ACHIEVE THAT AS WELL.
WELL THANK YOU HAVE A PLAN THAT
WE THERE IS A PLAN IN PLACE TO
BE ABLE TO INCREASE THOSE
NUMBERS INDICATE MORE BODIES
THROUGH- THE ACADEMY AND TO GET
THEM MORE BODIES OUT ON THE
ROAD OKAY SO IT SOUNDS MORE
LIKE A PRACTICAL ISSUE. IN
ADDITION TO NOT JUST A
FINANCIAL RESOURCES ISSUE RIGHT.
OKAY I ONLY HAD ONE LAST
QUESTION BIG MIKE. ASKED ALL OF
THE QUESTIONS WERE. TO OFFICER
TO AND AN ACCEPT DRUG IN TERMS
OF- HOUSING IN PAST DISCUSSIONS
WITH CHP WE LEARNED THAT
GRADUATING OFFICERS ARE GIVEN
THE OPTION IN THE
DISTRICT WHERE THEY LIVE
PROVIDED THEY OWN A HOME IN
THAT LOCATION. WHAT OTHER
FACTORS DO YOU CONSIDER WHEN
MAKING PLACEMENT DECISIONS HAS
THE DEPARTMENT EVER CONSIDERED
EXPANDED THE OPTION TO WORK FOR
A LIVING COMMUNITIES THEY HAVE
CLOSE TIES TO. REGARDLESS OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP I THINK THAT GETS
MAYBE IN SOME PIECES TO THE
DIVERSITY ISSUE OR THE- DO YOU
HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ON THAT AND I
DIDN'T. WARN YOU I WAS GOING TO
ASK THIS QUESTION SO. NO
WORRIES AT ALL MAN- ACTUALLY
THIS IS- AREA THAT WE TACKLED
ABOUT A YEAR AGO AND WE
ACTUALLY JUST WE DID CHANGE OUR
POLICY. WITH REGARD TO-
EXPANDING THAT THAT WAS A
CONCERN OF MINE AS WELL WHEN I
REVIEWED ON HOW WE EVALUATE
WORK AT THAT IS GOING TO GO. SO
WE DID EXPAND THAT NOT JUST
THAT YOU HAVE TO OWN A HOME BUT
EVEN IF YOU'RE THERE ARE YOU
SHOWED YOUR FROM THAT
COMMUNITY. THAT THOSE ARE
FACTORS THAT ARE NOW CONSIDERED
AN WHERE THEY COULD DANCE WILL
BE ABLE TO GO AFTER THEY
GRADUATE SO YES BECAUSE SOME
PEOPLE ARE RENTING SOME PEOPLE
HAVE APARTMENTS THAT DOESN'T
STAY STILL MAJOR PART OF THAT
COMMUNITY. YOU KNOW NOT JUST
OWNING A HOME SO WE DID EXPAND
THOSE PARAMETERS. THANK YOU
WELL THAT'S GOOD TO HEAR. I'M I
APPRECIATE. YOUR COMMENTS AND-
I REMEMBER WHEN YOU WERE
ACTUALLY PROMOTED TO ASSISTANT
COMMISSIONER CHIEF AN
ASSISTANT- THAT WAS A BIG DEAL
THAT WAS- A PROMOTION THAT WAS
NOTED BECAUSE- OF. OUR EYES THE
FACT THAT YOU'RE A WOMAN THE
FIRST WOMAN OBVIOUSLY A
TRAILBLAZER. AGAIN WELL
QUALIFIED IT'S REALLY GOOD TO
SEE. YOU HERE TODAY AND TO GET
TO HEAR FROM YOU VERY DIRECTLY
YOUR VISIONS AND YOUR- YOUR
WORK IN YOUR HOPES FOR- MOVING
CHP FORWARD AND MEETING THE
NEEDS OF YOUR OFFICERS. AS WELL
AS THE COMMUNITIES SO. YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU MA'AM I BELIEVE
THE TIME OF ALL THE YOU AND
REALLY GIVEN ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY AS
I TELL YOU- YOU KNOW WHY IN
TALKING WITH SENATOR LAYERED
HAVE DEFINITELY NOT READY YET
TO GO TO SHADY PINES WITH THE
REST OF THE GOLDEN GIRLS
THERE'S MORE WORK. AND I REALLY
WANT TO BE A PART OF THAT THE
WORK IN THAT EFFORT. YOU FOR-
YOU OBVIOUSLY TAPPED INTO
SENATOR LAYERED SENSE OF HUMOR.
THIS IS WHY SHE'S BEEN PROMOTED
AGAIN AND AGAIN OBVIOUSLY. NO
IT'S BEEN IT'S BEEN AN
ENJOYABLE CONVERSATION WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC NOW UNLESS OR FURTHER
COME. TO SENATOR GROWTH PLEASE
I DID NOTICE SOMETHING WHEN MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES WAS
ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
QUALIFICATION PRACTICES FOR
WOMEN BEING LOWER THAN MEN AND
I DID NOTICE THAT YOU HAVE AN
EXPERT RANGE BADGE ON YOUR
POCKET. AND SO OBVIOUSLY IT
DIDN'T AFFECT YOU VERY MUCH US
MA'AM IS THAT NIGHT AND LIKE
THE REST OF THE PEOPLE LIKE I
SAID I REALLY I WORK MY BEHIND
OFF I WAS NOT A GREAT SHOT WHEN
I GOT THERE BUT YOU KNOW THEY
WORK WITH ME AND I WAS ABLE TO-
BECOME PRETTY DARN GOOD AT IT.
WITH A LOT OF WORK. IN A MATTER.
THANK YOU SENATOR LIAR. I FEEL
OBLIGATED TO EXPLAIN. IF YOU
JUST SAY THAT ONE I WENT
THROUGH MY OWN CONFIRMATION
HEARING SINCE I PLAY ON A
TRIVIA TEAM NAMES SHADY PINES.
I WAS CHALLENGED TO WORK THAT
PHRASE INTO MY CONFIRMATION
HEARING BECAUSE THEY SAID THEY
WOULD BUY ME UNLIMITED HERE'S-
AND IN RESPONSE TO SENATOR DALY
ON I DID THAT AND SO I JUST
WOULD LIKE TO SAY. I HOPE SHE
GOT SOMETHING FOR THAT. THAT
THAT MADE ME THINK OF THE
QUESTION SENATOR LAYERED WHAT
DID YOU PROMISED HER IF SHE
WORKED THAT INTO. THAT DOES NOT
HAPPEN HERE THAT NO NO I I'M
DOES NOT HAPPEN HERE. DOESNOT
HAPPEN HERE. AND I WILL SLOW
DOWN. THIS IS YOUR LIFE IF WELL
OKAY WE ARE GOING TO- GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC- THAT A
REMINDER TO WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO PROVIDE COMMENT VIA PHONE AS
WE START OUT WITH PEOPLE WHO
MAY BE HERE IN PUBLIC- IF YOU
WANT TO PROVIDE COMMENT VIA
PHONE THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AGAIN IS. 844-291-4185
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. THREE
THREE EIGHT ZERO FOUR SIX WE'RE
GONNA START RIGHT HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE- I
ACTUALLY DO NOT SEE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC YOU'RE STEPPING
FORWARD TO TESTIFY WE DO HAVE A
SECOND ROOM. I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND LOOK AT MY SCREEN AND SEE
IF THERE IS ANYONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. I DON'T SEE ANYONE
APPROACHING THE PODIUM IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. SO AT THIS POINT I
AM GOING TO TEE UP OUR
MODERATOR WELCOME THE MODERATOR
AND ASK IF YOU WOULD- ROMPED
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE WAITING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
CAN ONLY HAVE SIX THANK YOU
YOU'RE WELCOME. SIX BEFORE WE
GO AHEAD LET ME- LET ME REMIND
WITNESSES. THAT WE'RE GONNA
AGAIN ASK THAT WHEN YOU SPEAK
YOU PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND
POSITION ON THE APPOINTMENT.
AND THEN AGAIN ON BEHALF OF OUR
COURT REPORTER PLEASE SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY GO AHEAD
MADAM MODERATOR. GREAT THANK
YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE'RE
GOING TO OPEN LINE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE PLEASED TO
COURT GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT OF
COMMISSIONER. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH HER
AND HER DEPARTMENT AT ONE OF
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS-
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND YOUR NAME
IS- JEAN MICHEL MUTCHLER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
MADAME MODERATOR. THE LINE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ERIN
READ WHAT WAS IN THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION I WOULD COME IN I
THOUGHT I WAS GOING TO LAST
BECAUSE OUR PRESIDENT IS GOING
TO TESTIFY IN IN SUPPORT OF THE
COMMISSIONER BUT I GUESS WHEN I
HAD MY- SUPPORT AS WELL. AS YOU
ALL KNOW ME I'VE HAD A CHANCE
TO WORK WITH COMMISSIONER MANY
TIMES AS DOES THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COMMON.
DISAPPEARING FROM OUR PRESIDENT.
Q. THANK YOU MUCH MATTER
MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS. ONE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
SPENDING REVIEWS ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL ORGANIZATION OF
BLACK LAW ENFORCEMENT
EXECUTIVES MOBILE I AM TONY FOR
CERTAIN ANSWERING THE SIX VICE
PRESIDENT. AND THE COMMANDER
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY THE VISION OF THE
LAUGHTER STATE TROOPERS. I'M
HONORED TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY ON
BEHALF OF COMMISSIONER AMANDA
RATE. I'M TO THANK GOD W. FOR
DISCUSS APPOINTMENT. YOU READY
OF THE THIRTY ONE YEAR. AND
PONDERED ONE WITHIN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AT THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN TO SERVE
WRAPPED UP TO THE COMMISSION.
BUT CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
SO I HAVE NOT WORKED DIRECTLY
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT WILL
COMMISSIONERATE. OUR MARKET
COMMITMENT TO SERVICE.
CONDITIONALLY HOLD FIRM TO THE
VALUES FORTH BY THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL. BUILDING TRUST
AND LEGITIMACY BUT THE
COMMUNITY SHE CERTAIN. WALDRON
ASHCOMBE DOOR COMMISSION
REAPPOINTMENT TO SORRY ABOUT
THE COMMISSION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND MAY
GOD BLESS YOU ALL AND SIR WOULD
YOU GIVE ME YOUR NAME AGAIN.
ONLY A POOL OF BLOOD MUCH THANK
YOU I MISSED IT THE FIRST TIME
I'M SO SORRY THANK YOU. MADAME
MODERATOR PAUL THANK YOU.
MADAME MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS.
BLANK FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OUR MEMBERS PLANNING
BONITA AND ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA WILL NEED LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR A
COMBINATION OF A MANTA RAY FOR
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
COMMISSIONER HAVING THEM BLURRY
CLEAR AND TRIGONOMETRICAL
SURVEY AND HAS. AN IMPASSIONED
TELLING THE PART IN AND- DAY-
THE STORM DARK MOMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA AND THERE'S NO
BETTER CANDIDATES ABOUT THE
ISSUES AMANDA RANT THAT PROVEN
LEADER WITH PART INTEGRITY AND
EXPERTISE THAT WILL BE A GREAT.
ASSET TO THE DEPARTMENT ABOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ON
FRIDAY AND HE AGAIN- I HEAR
KICKED THE COURTS. AND AND I
HER CONFIRMATION FOR CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL COMMISSIONER
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS MADAME MODERATOR. NINE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON IS DOCTOR K. BROWNING
THANK DIRECTOR OF THE TEAM TRY
THE NONPROFIT WORK. THAT TO YOU
COMMUNITY BASE PRO AND RECKLESS
AND DISTRACTED DRIVING I'VE HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES
AND THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL IS UNRIVALED IN ITS
PROFESSIONALISM AND COMMITMENT
TO THE COMMUNITIES IT SERVES
WE ARE ESPECIALLY EXCITED TO
HAVE COMMISSIONER RAY AT THE
HOME FIELD EXPERIENCE INCLUDING
THIRTY ONE YEARS OF SERVICE
WITH CHP COUPLED WITH OUR
COMPASSION AND COMMITMENT TO
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND PUBLIC
SERVICE WILL ALLOW HER TO LEAD
CALIFORNIA'S FINEST TO THIS
UNIQUE TIME OF PLACE
REEVALUATION. JUST OF IMPACTING
DRIVERS STRIVE TO CHANGE THE
CULTURE OF DRIVING TO ONE THAT
IS DISTRACTION FREE I BELIEVE
COMMISSIONER RAY CAN CHANGE THE
CULTURE POLICING TO BOLSTER AND
SAFEGUARD MUTUAL RESPECT AND
TRUST BETWEEN CHP OFFICERS AND
CALIFORNIANS. I TRULY BELIEVE
SHE IS THE RIGHT PERSON AT THE
RIGHT TIME TO CARRY THE
NATION'S LARGEST STATE POLICE
AGENCY FORWARD AND ENSURE IT
PROVIDES THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
SAFETY SERVICE AND SECURITY TO
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SUPPORT COMMISSIONERATE. THANK
YOU VERY. MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. ONE THIRTY SECOND LINE
IS NOW. GOOD AFTERNOON SHE
RECKONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS GREG DUBUQUE AND I'M
THE PRESIDENT OF LIBERTY LINE
HALL WEST BASED IN MONTEBELLO
AND I'M ALSO THIS YEAR'S
PRESIDENT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION. ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION AND ITS
FIFTEEN HUNDRED MEMBERS WE
SUPPORT THE CONFIRMATION OF
COMMISSIONERATE AS THE
COMMISSIONER OF THE LARGEST
STATE HIGHWAY PATROL YOU CAN
SEE IN THE NATION THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL. SHE
TEARS AND JOY TO A LONGSTANDING
GREAT WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE C. H. P. C. P. AND C. H.
CLEAR PARTNERS IN CT THE
COLLABORATIVELY OVER THE YEARS
WE HAVE WORKED ON MANY
COMMERCIAL TRUCK SAFETY
INITIATIVES. ONE OF WHICH IS
THE BI ANNUAL COMMERCIAL
VEHICLE SAFETY SUMMIT. THE
SUMMIT STARTED OVER THIRTEEN
YEARS AGO. AND HAS CONSISTENTLY
OVER FOUR HUNDRED TRUCKING
COMPANY REPRESENTATIVES
ATTENDED THIS DAY LONG EVENT
WHICH STRESSES THE IMPORTANCE
OF SAFETY BY HAVING INTERACTIVE
EDUCATIONAL SESSIONS TAUGHT BY
CHP PERSONNEL. I ALSO MIGHT ADD
THIS IS THE ONLY COMMERCIAL
VEHICLE SEATING SOME OF ITS
KIND IN THE NATION. I DO. TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY MESSAGE DID
NOT GET OVERLOOKED DURING THE
PANDEMIC C. H. P. OFFERED AND
PRESENTED MANY COMMERCIAL MOTOR
VEHICLE SAFETY PRESENTATIONS
FOR OUR MEMBERS OVER THIS PAST
YEAR. THESE WEBINARS WERE
EXTREMELY WELL ATTENDED.
COMMISSIONERATE HIT IS NO
STRANGER TO OUR MEMBERSHIP FOR
SURE. OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS
SHE'S CLIMBED THE RANKS OF THE
CHP SHE HAS ATTENDED AND BEING
THE KEYNOTE SPEAKER AT MANY
OPERATE RIDER OF THE YEAR AND
FLEET CD BANQUETS. THESE EVENTS
RECOGNIZED AS THE BEST AND
SAFEST DRIVERS AND FLEET IN THE
STATE. NERY ALWAYS TAKES THE
TIME TO MEET THE DRIVERS IN OUR
MEMBERS AND GRACIOUSLY ALWAYS
TOO EASILY TO TAKE PICTURES
WITH THE WINNERS. BELIEVE ME
GETTING THE PICTURE WITH THE
TOP LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL IN
OUR STATE IS A IS A HIGHLY OF
THE VENT FOR DRIVERS. I ALSO
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR SINCERE
THANKS TO THE COMMISSIONER. WHO
AFTER SHE WAS RECENTLY NAMED
COMMISSIONER SHE JUST HER
SCHEDULE TO MAKE SURE SHE STUCK
TO HER COMMITMENT TO ADDRESS
OUR MEMBERSHIP DURING OUR
ANNUAL MEMBERSHIP CONFERENCE.
EVEN THOUGH WAS IN REVENGE SHE
STILL DREW A BIG VIRTUAL
APPLAUSE IN APPRECIATION AND
SUPPORT IN HER ROLE AS A
COMMISSIONER. IN CLOSING CGA
HAS ENJOYED A GREAT WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE C. H. P.
FOR MANY YEARS. AND LOOKS
FORWARD TO BACK CONTINUE
RELATIONSHIP AS COMMISSIONERATE
LEAVES THE CHP. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPRESS SEEKING SUPPORT
INTEGRATION GRADUATIONS
COMMISSIONERATE. THANK YOU.
MADAM MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DR YOLANDA
FRIDAY AND I'M A MEMBER OF THE
C. H. P. CITIZENS ADVISORY
BOARD REPRESENTING THE IN
DIVISION. I'M CURRENTLY THE
DEAN OF THE SCHOOL OF BUSINESS
AND APPLY TECHNOLOGY AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THAT
CHEEKY COLLEGE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IT IS MY HONOR AND
PLEASURE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
COMMISSIONER REYES CONFIRMATION
TODAY. WE ARE SINCERELY PROUD
OF HER RECORD OF ACHIEVEMENT IN
HER FAST THE OLD TECHNICAL
OPERATIONAL EXPERTISE. AND THE
FIRST WOMAN TO LEAD THE CHP WE
ARE EXCITED ABOUT COMMISSIONER
RAY AND THE VALUE SHE BRINGS TO
THE ENTERPRISE ESPECIALLY HER
DESIRE TO ENGAGE WITH OUR
COMMUNITY AND TO ENSURE THAT
THE CHP LEADS THE PACK IN THE
BELTING TRAINING AND PROGRAMS
THAT EMPHASIZE. THAT ONLY THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF SAFETY AND
SECURITY WHAT THE STUPID
TIFFANY IN AWARENESS OF THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE PEOPLE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. AND EDUCATE
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
HOMELAND SECURITY ARE AMONG THE
AREAS THAT I OVERSEE WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING HOW WE CAN WORK WITH
OUR ADVISORY PANEL SUGGESTS
CURRICULUM TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR INCOMING LAW ENFORCEMENT
THAT. IN PERSON NOW HAVE
UNDERSTANDING AND APPRECIATION
FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE AND THE
COMPANY WILL WORK AROUND
POLICING. I'D LIKE TO PROVIDE
MY PRELIMINARY THANKS THE CHP
FOR SETTING THE STANDARD FOR
OTHER AGENCIES IN THIS REGARD.
LASTLY I'D LIKE TO SHARE WORDS
WOULD HAVE TO LEAVE I MILLER
NOW OF THE BAKERSFIELD DIVISION
WHICH TACKLE MY SENTIMENTS AND
SYMPTOMATIC. OF THE MEMBERS AT
THE CAB. YOUR REYES GROUNDED IN
CONCORD. AND AUTHENTICALLY WHO
IS. TO A CALL OF TRUST. SHE
WOULD OTHER THAT SIX AS A
EMPLOYEE. BRIDGE AND PIONEER.
SHE WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE CHP
IN ORGANIZATIONS THE STATE CAN
BE PROUD OF. WE ARE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY IN SUPPORT OF
DISAPPOINTMENT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
CONGRATULATIONS AND BEST WISHES
TO COMMISSIONER COMMANDER
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS.
ONE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TIM CHANG WITH THE
AUTO CLUB OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA- WE'D LIKE TO JOIN
THE CHORUS UP INDOORS MEANT FOR
A MANTA RAY AS THE NEXT
COMMISSIONER OF THE HIGHWAY
PATROL. THE AUTO CLUB HAS HAD
LONG STANDING RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE HIGHWAY PATROL --
LOOKING TO SERVE CALIFORNIA
MOTORISTS IN MAKING THE ROADS
SAFER FOR EVERYONE TO USE
THEM WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT
THAT WILL CONTINUE UNDER
COMMISSIONER REYES COMMAND
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE ONE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN -- GOOD AFTERNOON KIRK
BLACKBURN CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TOW TRUCK
ASSOCIATION AND THE WESTERN
STATE TRUCKING ASSOCIATIONS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
CONFIRMATION OF THE MANDARIN
AS COMMISSIONER OF THE CHP
WE APPLAUD THIS THOUGHTFUL
SELECTIONS AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
COMMISSIONER RENT AND ARE GREAT
ABOUT MOVING FORWARD THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE BEFORE WE
OPEN NINE THIRTY SEVEN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN
GOOD AFTERNOON RESPECTED
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RICK
PULASKI PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ARBITRAL AND ON BEHALF OF
THE FOURTEEN THOUSAND ACTIVE
AND RETIRED MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HIGHWAY PATROLMEN IT
IS MY PLEASURE TO SUPPORT
COMMISSIONER AMANDA READY
FOR HER APPOINTMENT TO THE
POSITION OF CHP COMMISSIONER
COMMISSIONERATE HAS PROVEN
HERSELF AS A LEADER WHO
DEEPLY CARES ABOUT BOTH THE
EMPLOYEES WHO WORK FOR HER
AND THE PUBLIC THEY SERVE HER
LONG CAREER THE CHP OFFICER
AND HER PASSION FOR SERVICE TO
OTHERS GIVE HER THE EXPERIENCE
TO LEAD THAT ONE OF THE MOST
CHALLENGING TIMES IN RECENT
MEMORY FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
WE HOPE THE WHOLE
HEARTEDLY OFFER OUR SUPPORT FOR
HER APPOINTMENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. AND
AT THE TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT. MADAME MODERATOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL BE
BACK WITH YOU MOMENTARILY. OKAY
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM ALL OF THE
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION- ANDLET'S
BEGIN WITH WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE.
AGAIN I DON'T SEE ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN THIS ROOM
SO I WILL LOOK AGAIN TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE OUR SECOND ROOM. I
SEE NO ONE APPROACHING THE
PODIUM SO MADAM MODERATOR WE
ARE BACK WITH YOU ALREADY. TO
SEE IF YOU CAN T. UP PEOPLE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS THE ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND MADAM WE HAVE NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE WE
APPRECIATE IT I WILL BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND SEE I SEE. I SEE
EVERYONE'S HAND I SEE
EVERYONE'S HAND BUT ALL
RECOGNIZE SENATOR LAYERED I
WOULD MOVE THE CONFIRMATION OF
AMANDA REYES COMMISSIONER FOR
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL.
THANK YOU SENATOR MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. GROSS I GROW BY KAMLAGER
I LONGER ROI LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES HI I. ATKINS FIVE INSIDE.
A MAN COMMISSIONER IT IS A IN
THROUGH CAS STICK UNANIMOUS
VOTE CONGRADULATIONS WILL MOVE
YOU TO THE FLOOR OF THE SENATE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TO EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS AND JUST NOW AS
A COMMISSIONER I AM COMMITTED
TO ENSURING CHP REMAINS
EVALUATIVE ARE RECOUP THE
STRATEGIES BRANDING AND
COMMUNITY OUTREACH THANK YOU SO
MUCH APPRECIATE IT I THINK WE
FEEL CONFIDENT THAT IS TRUE
CONGRATULATIONS COMMISSIONER.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A I JUST A
SHORT BREAK. FOR LESS THAN FIVE
MINUTES SO WE SHALL RECONVENE
IN FIVE MINUTES THANK YOU.
ALL
OUR MEETINGS BACK INTO SESSION
AND LET ME START BY SAYING
THANK YOU MS LANDS BURKE FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WE SO
APPRECIATED- THIS WILL BE ITEM
ONE B. THE APPOINTMENT OF
ELIZABETH A LANCE BURKE JD
DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT. SO LET ME WELCOME
YOU. AND ASK YOU TO INTRODUCE
YOURSELF ANYONE WITH YOU THAT
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ORDER
KNOWLEDGE ANYONE THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND MAKE YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS WHATEVER YOU'D
LIKE TO SHARE WITH US AND THEN
WE'LL GO RIGHT TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS. WELCOME THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MADAM VICE CHAIR
SENATORS GROW CALLED LOGGER AND
LAYERED AND CONGRADULATIONS TO
COMMISSIONER RAY IT IS AN HONOR
TO SHARE THE VIRTUAL PLATFORM.
FOR THE VIRTUAL PODIUM WITH YOU
KNOW. I APPRECIATE GOVERNOR
NEWSOM IN SECRETARY GALLEY IN
TRUSTING ME WITH THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND I'M HUMBLED TO
BE BEFORE YOU TODAY. I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE SPECIAL PEOPLE
WHO ARE WITH ME BOTH IN PERSON
AND VIRTUALLY. MY AMAZING
SUPPORTIVE HUSBAND GORDON DEAN.
MY WONDERFUL OFFSPRING JACOB
AND AURY. MY SISTER RACHEL
LANDSBERG SUPPORT SYSTEM
EXTRAORDINAIRE AND MY PARENTS
WRITER DOROTHY LANDSBERG WHO
EVERY DAY MODEL THE VALUES OF
PUBLIC SERVICE. SOCIAL JUSTICE
AND COMMUNITY CONNECTION I
HAVE BEEN SO LUCKY TO HAVE HAD
MANY INCREDIBLE MENTORS AND
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE PUT THEIR
TRUST IN NEED TO TAKE ON
MEANINGFUL WORK AND WHO HAVE
TAUGHT ME HOW TO CREATE CHANGE
AND EACH OF US CAN HELP MAKE
THE CHANGE WE WANT TO SEE IN
THE WORLD. I THANK EACH OF YOU
FOR YOUR GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT.
HAVING SPENT THIRTY YEARS
WORKING IN SOCIAL SERVICES.
ADVOCACY AND HEALTH CARE I
BRING WITH ME THE HEALTHCARE
CONSUMERS. THE WOMEN ESCAPING
VIOLENCE. THOSE FIGHTING FOR
THEIR CIVIL RIGHTS BUT I'VE HAD
THE PRIVILEGE TO WORK WITH AND
LEARN FROM. HAVING ADVOCATED
FOR ACCESS TO QUALITY
AFFORDABLE EQUITABLE HEALTH
CARE FOR TWENTY YEARS I AM
THRILLED TO HAVE THE
pOFFENSE VERY PORTFOLIO. MY
LEGAL CAREER STARTED FOCUSED ON
CIVIL RIGHTS AND WOMEN'S RIGHTS
CORNELL USE THAT I BRING TO MY
APPROACH TO HEALTH CARE. I HOPE
TO HELP THE DEPARTMENT CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE SAFE HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES. FINANCING AND THE
CRITICAL HEALTHCARE DATASETS
THAT WE ABLE TO WORK WITH. AND
WE HAVE EXCITING PROPOSALS MANY
OF WHICH ARE IN FRONT OF YOU TO
INCREASE OUR IMPACT IN BUILDING
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO SERVE OUR DIVERSE
STATE. AND HELP AND THE COST
HER HEALTH CARE WHILE IMPROVING
QUALITY OF CARE. WITH THIS
GROWING SET OF WORK WE ARE
POISED TO GRADUATE FROM AN
OFFICE TO A DEPARTMENT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
ACCESS AND INFORMATION H. HIGH.
RECOGNIZING THE ONGOING CRISIS
OF RACIAL INEQUITY I WILL BE
PROACTIVE IN ADDRESSING EQUITY
BOTH AS A WORKPLACE AND IN OUR
PROGRAM FOR. THOUGH I HAVE ONLY
WORKED WITH THE COMMITTED AND
TALENTED STAFF AT ALL SHE SAID
FOR LESS THAN FIVE MONTHS I AM
AWED BY THEIR COMMITMENT TO
EXCELLENCE AND KNOW THAT WE
WILL ACCOMPLISH GREAT THINGS
TOGETHER I AM HONORED TO BE
HERE AND WELCOME YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- YOU LOOK POISED AND
READY SENATOR LAYERED SO I WILL
START WITH YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND- I ENJOYED THE MEETING
YESTERDAY AND THEN I WAS
WALKING THROUGH THE CAPITOL.
AND THERE YOU WERE ON THE
SCREEN TESTIFYING IN FRONT OF
THE SENATE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
SO YOU MUST'VE DONE HEAVY
SENATE DUTY YESTERDAY. AND I
JUST WANT TO TALK ABOUT A
COUPLE OF THINGS THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT DURING THE MEETING- ONE
IS A SAID. WHEN I DID MY-
ASSEMBLY SERVICE THERE WAS SUCH
A BACKLOG OF HOSPITAL
APPLICATIONS ANOTHER CINEMA AT
THAT THERE WAS. IT WOULD TAKE
YEARS PEOPLE WOULD LOSE
CONTRACTORS PEOPLE WOULD LOSE
GRANTS AND IN OUR TALK
YESTERDAY FROM IT SOUNDS LIKE
THAT DOESN'T EXIST ANYMORE BUT
I WONDERED IF YOU JUST TALK
ABOUT HOW EXPEDITIOUSLY YOU
PROCESS THE THINGS THAT ARE IN
FRONT OF HIM. ABSOLUTELY CENTER
LATER THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION AND SO AS WE TALKED
ABOUT YESTERDAY I'VE BEEN
REALLY IMPRESSED WITH MY STAFF
AND THE INNOVATIONS THAT
THEY'RE UNDERTAKING TO TRY TO
IMPROVE. THE HOSPITAL SAFETY
BUILDING PROCESS WHILE%
MAINTAINING THIS THE STANDARDS
TO WHICH WE HAVE TO KEEP SO WE
ARE LOOKING AT- DOING MORE AND
MORE ELECTRONICALLY AS IS
NECESSARY RIGHT NOW WE ARE
SCANNING ALL OF OUR HOSPITAL.
LANDS THAT WOULD THAT TAKE UP A
LOT OF STORAGE SPACE RIGHT NOW
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
HOSPITALS WHAT HOSPITAL SUBMITS
A PLAN FOR WHETHER IT'S A NEW
BUILDING OR CORRECTIONS THAT.
WE GIVE THEM AT EXPECTED TIME
FRAME AT THE FRONT END AND THEY
WERE MEASURING OURSELVES IN
THEM AGAINST THAT TIME FRAME SO
WE'RE I'VE BEEN VERY IMPRESSED
WITH THE WITH THE DATA THAT WE
COLLECT- IN TERMS OF MEASURING
OURSELVES. WE KEEP TRACK OF HOW
MUCH BACK AND FORTH THERE IS
WITH THE DESIGN TEAM AT THE
HOSPITAL AND WE'RE TRACKING OUR
RESPONSE RATES TO MAKE SURE
RESPONSIVE. WE'RE ALSO TRYING
TO DO BETTER COORDINATION WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WHICH LICENSES
THE SERVICES TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S A CONSISTENT. APPROACH
AND MESSAGING TO THE HOSPITAL'S
CENTER WE HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPROVED OUR SERVICE IN OUR
TIME FRAME SINCE YOUR YOUR TIME
IN THE ASSEMBLY GOOD AND I KNOW
YOU REFERENCE SEISMIC SAFETY
AND I KNOW THAT THERE ARE A LOT
THAT STILL MIGHT BE COMING YOUR
WAY FROM. OUR HOSPITALS. THEN
MAYBE LASTLY IS SECOND QUESTION
IS. COULD YOU JUST TALK ABOUT.
YOU YOU GET A- APPOINTED AND
THEN THE PANDEMIC HAPPENS COULD
YOU TALK ABOUT HOW. JEFF THE
WHOLE DEPARTMENT S. DON IT IN
TERMS OF- BEING REMOTE AND
STILL GETTING BUSINESS DONE AND
JUST HOW YOU OF SURVIVOR DURING
THE PANDEMIC. YES THANK YOU
SENATOR SO I CAN'T TAKE CREDIT
FOR THE WORK THAT WAS DONE TO
MOVE US TO TELEWORK- ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY WHEN THE GOVERNOR-
ISSUE THE STATE HOME ORDER BUT
LAST MARCH THAT IS WHAT
HAPPENED FORTUNATELY WE HAD-
PURCHASE LAPTOPS FOR ALL OF OUR
STAFF. WELL OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE
FIELD STAFF AND HAD TO MAINTAIN
THEIR PRESENCE IN THE FIELD AND
ACTUALLY HAD IT INCREASED NEED
DURING THE HOSPITAL SURGE- IN
DECEMBER JANUARY AND FEBRUARY
SO WE MAINTAIN FIELD STAFF
WHERE WE HAD TO MAKE SURE THEY
HAVE THE PROTECTIVE. EQUIPMENT
THEY NEEDED TO STAY SAFE BUT-
COULDN'T BE PROUDER OF THE JOB
THAT THE PHOTO STAFF IS DONE.
WORKING REMOTELY AS WITH MOST
DEPARTMENTS WE HAVE STAFF THAT
HAVE BEEN DEPLOYED TO HELP WITH
CONTACT TRACING AND TESTING AND
AS EXPERTS IN HOSPITAL
BUILDINGS AND BUILDINGS IN
GENERAL I WISH THAT IS NOT A
LOT OF WORK TO TRY TO SUPPORT
THE STATE DURING THE COPA
RESPONSE AND SO WE HAVE- WE'VE
HELPED HOSPITALS WITH THEIR
OXYGEN SUPPLY ISSUES. WE HAVE
REVIEWED ALTERNATE CARE SITES
THAT HOSPITALS HAVE SET UP
AGAIN DURING THE WORST OF THE
SURGE BUT THE DAY IN DAY OUT
WORK ON THIS HAPPENING IN
PEOPLE'S HOMES AS I AM TODAY-
AND WE'RE REALLY DOING A GREAT
JOB OF MAINTAINING THE MOMENTUM
EVEN WITH THE PANDEMIC. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR MADAM VICE CHAIR.
FOR WOMAN THE VICE CHAIRWOMAN
FORGIVE ME. HERE WHATEVER. WITH
I DON'T WANT TO BE IN VIOLATION
OF SENATOR LAYERED PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT WE JUST PASSED
OUT OF THE SENATE YES BUT NOW I
KNOW I CAN AMEND THE WORD
WHATEVER INTO IT. REMEMBER MY
NAME PAT YOU CAN GO CAIR WOMEN
SHARE MAN WHATEVER I THINK THAT
WAS A JOKE ON FNL LONG TIME AGO
SO I'M GOOD I'M GOOD. ANYWAY-
WE HAVE NEED A LITTLE LEVITY AS
WE APPROACH SOME OF THESE VERY
DIFFICULT ISSUES AND HEALTH
CARE AND- I KNOW MY COLLEAGUE-
CENTER TRULY OR DUDE OF KIND OF
TOUCH A LITTLE BIT ON THE
SEISMIC ISSUE. AND LET ME BEGIN
WITH SAYING I AM SORRY THAT WE
DID NOT HAVE TIME YESTERDAY-
DIRECTOR LANCE BURKE FOR ME TO
HAVE A ON ONE ON ONE WITH YOU
AND I'D LIKE TO DO THAT BUT IT
WAS JUST ONE OF THOSE. ONE OF
THOSE DAYS- ACTUALLY SO. I DO
APOLOGIZE. THAT TUB. JUST
QUICKLY ON THE FISA MAKE ISSUE
I WITH THE BOARD HOSPITAL BOARD
MEMBER AND NUMBER OF YEARS AGO
WHEN THE FIRST REQUIREMENT FOR
THAT CAME THROUGH. AND WAS FIVE
SIGNIFICANTLY YOU KNOW EXTENDED
EACH TIME WITH WITH I THINK
SOME. REMEDIATION IS REQUIRED
BUT I THINK WHAT'S IMPORTANT
NOW SUB. HAVING SPOKEN WITH MY
HOSPITALS RECENTLY OF FIGHT TO-
I THINK ENSURE THAT OUR
SPENDING IN THE ADMINISTRATION
ARE WORKING WITH OUR HOSPITALS.
AND THE OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
FIND A SOLUTION IT KIND OF
BALANCES THE NEEDS OF THAT IF
YOU COULD KIND OF A DRAFT THAT
IS YOU'RE GOING FORWARD IF THIS
VERY VERY IMPORTANT OPPOSITION
YOU NOW HAVE. A BECAUSE I THINK
ON BOTH SIDES SO YOU KNOW
THEY'RE SO THEY'RE SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES AND CONCERNS THAT HAVE
TO BE ADDRESSED. HANDO THAT
FALLS IN YOUR LAP I ASSUME THAT
YOU KNOW AND IN THE SHORT AND
ALL THE LONG TERM ALSO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER BATES AND
YES SO- IT IS WITHIN US PETS-
RANGE OF DUTIES TO REVIEW
SEISMIC STANDARDS AND TO SET
THOSE STANDARDS AND WE ARE
AWARE OF COURSE OF THE LAST TWO
YEARS. HAVE PRESENTED-
UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGES TO THE
HOSPITAL SO WE WERE WE WERE
WITH THEM- LITERALLY AS THEY
STRUGGLE TO SET UP SPACE DURING
THE SEARCHES AND WERE
OVERWHELMED SO WE KNOW THAT
THEY HAVE NOT. HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE BUSINESS AS
USUAL OVER THE LAST YEAR I'M AT
THE SAME TIME OF COURSE PATIENT
SAFETY AND STAFF SAFETY IS
CRITICAL. AND SO I'M CURRENTLY
THERE IS A TWENTY THIRTY
STANDARD AND THEN THERE ARE
DISCUSSIONS UNDERWAY TO SEE
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE-
REGARDING THAT TWENTY THIRTY
STANDARD AGAIN FINDING THE
BALANCE- UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
DIFFICULTY HOSPITALS HAVE BEEN
UNDER AND ARE ALSO TRYING TO
MAINTAIN THAT. THE NEED TO
FOCUS ON PATIENT SAFETY. THANK
YOU I OUT DOUBT FIVE GIVE I'D
WOULDN'T CALL IT GOOD NEWS
GREAT NEWS BUT IT'S REALLY THE
KIND OF NEWS WE WANT TO HEAR
ABOUT THEIR SAW CERTAINLY ON.
CONTINUING KHAN THE
CONVERSATIONS AND CERTAINLY I
HAVE A REAL COMMITMENT TO FIND
A BALANCE THERE. AND THAT'S
BASICALLY WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT
CERTAINLY- I AM ALSO CONCERNED
ABOUT THE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY AND THESE COST
HEALTH CARE. COST TARGETS OF
CERTAINLY WE'VE LEARNED THAT
YOU CAN'T COOKIE CUTTER. OF THE
COST OF VARIOUS MEDICAL
PROCEDURES. ARE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WE'VE SEEN GREAT OF.
DIVERGENCE IN COSTS FOR
DIFFERENT PROCEDURES ESPECIALLY
I THINK IN THE ORTHOPEDIC WORLD
WHERE. THE REPLACEMENTS AND
SOME PARTICULAR HOSPITAL. OUR
SYSTEMS ARE AT ONE COSTS AND
OTHER THOUGH THERE ARE
DIFFERENT COST SO HOW HOW WILL
YOU APPROACH. OF THAT WHOLE
DISCUSSION OF. TARGET AND- AS
IMPORTANTLY IF THE TARGETS
AREN'T BEING MET ONCE THEY'RE
SET. OUT WHAT APPEARED TO BE
RATHER SEVERE PENALTIES. THAT
ARE AT LEAST BEING DISCUSSED.
THANK YOU CENTER FOR SO YOU
WORK. TO THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED
OFF OF HEALTH FOR. IT WOULD BE
PLACED WITHIN OUR HEAD- WE
WOULD FOLLOW ON THE HEELS OF
SEVERAL OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
HAD GREAT SUCCESS IN TRYING TO
SET COST TARGETS- BUT OF COURSE
S ALWAYS VOID. BUT OUR OUR
CALIFORNIANS FIN ON IT SO-
FIRST AND FOREMOST WE'VE HEARD
FROM STAKEHOLDERS THE NEEDS- TO
WAIT IN TERMS OF WHEN THE THAT
COST TARGETS WOULD START AND SO
WE WOULD CERTAINLY NOT USED
CURRENT PANDEMIC DATA AS A
BASELINE DATA. WERE LOOKING TO
HAVE THE FIRST YEAR OF COST
TARGET STARTED TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR I KNOW ENFORCEABLE TARGETS
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. BUT
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA IN
TERMS OF HOW MUCH BUT HEALTH
CARE COSTS ARE INCREASING AS
COMPARED TO THE RATE OF
INFLATION- ITS FIVE TIMES
WEEKLY HAD A WEAPON ARE THIS
WITH THIS- OVER THE LUNCH
PERIOD TODAY AND LOOK AT SOME
REALLY STARTLING STATISTICS- SO
WE KNOW THAT FAMILIES. ARE
REALLY SUFFERING UNDER THE-
ANOTHER'S HI HOW CARE COSTS. AS
OUR- AND US IS THE STATE IS A
LARGE. OF HEALTH COVERAGE SO-
IT IS OUR VIEW THAT THE- COSTS
ARE INCREASING AT A RATE THAT'S
UNSUSTAINABLE- IN TERMS OF
SETTING COST TARGETS. WE HAVE
APPROACH OF HAVING- I ADVISORY
BOARD THAT WOULD SET THE COST
TARGETS THAT WOULD BE REVIEWED-
BY IT BY MY THE- IBM OR THE
DIRECTOR IN MY ROLE. AND IN
TERMS OF ENFORCEMENT WE WOULD
VERY MUCH LOOK TO A PROGRESSIVE
APPROACH SO THAT THE FIRST THAT
PEACE WOULD BE TO DO OUTREACH-
TO THE PARTY THAT MAY NOT HAVE
MET THE COST TARGETS UNDERSTAND
LOOK AT THE DATA. MORE
CAREFULLY WITH THEM THERE WOULD
BE AN APPEALS PROCESS. AS WELL
AS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS BEFORE
WE GOT ANYWHERE NEAR FINE SO WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT. TO BE
SERIOUS ABOUT ENFORCING BUT. IS
A PROGRESSIVE FORCES APPROACH.
I APPRECIATE THAT- I THINK
WHAT'S IMPORTANT FOR US AYE IN
THE LEGISLATURE THOUGH THE
LAWMAKERS AS YOU GO FORWARD
WITH WITH THE PLAN.
UNDERSTANDING WHAT ARE THE COST
DRIVERS AND HAVING A PRETTY
COMPLETE PRESENTATION. AND SOME
VALIDATION ON COMPARATIVE DATA
ON ON WHAT ARE THE COST DRIVERS
BECAUSE MANY TIMES IT IS ADDING
MORE SERVICES THAT ARE REQUIRED
TO BE COVERED BY OUR HEALTH
PLANS. AND I THINK OF HAT IS
BEEN ONE OF THE THINGS ARE
HAVING ONCE UPON A TIME SERVED
ON THAT BOARD WAS BEFORE H. M.
O.'S CAME INTO BEING. ONCE THEY
DID THE CAPITATION ISSUES ARE
BECAME SIGNIFICANT IN TERMS OF.
WHAT IT WAS COSTING FOR- YOU
KNOW COVERAGE SO THOSE ARE
THINGS THAT I WOULD LOOK FOR ON
IN TERMS OF. PROPOSED
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
BASICALLY ARE IMPLEMENTED BOB
COSTARRED GOOD FAN PUNISHMENT
FROM AND ALL OF THAT. LAST
QUESTION I HAVE IS- REGARDING
OUR HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE. AND I
THINK WE'RE ALL CONCERNED
BECAUSE CERTAINLY IF WE WANT TO
TALK ABOUT ACCESS WE CERTAINLY
HAVE TO HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
GOING TO PROVIDE US THE
SERVICE. SO WHAT DO YOU SEE ARE
THE MOST PRESSING HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE ISSUES. FACING THE
STATE AND- BOUGHT. FUND ON HOW
WE ADDRESS THOSE. THANK YOU. SO
AS YOU NOTED THERE AND LOT OF
HER. AND COMMISSIONS- OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS THAT REALLY
DELVED INTO THOSE- THAT IF BUT
IF NOTED THAT THE LACK OF
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS. ON THE OTHER
SPECIFIC TYPES OF PROVIDERS SO
WHEN I GOT TO ASK THE LESS THAN
FIVE MONTHS AGO I WAS CHARGED
RIGHT AWAY WITH. TRYING TO LOOK
AT THOSE REPORTS AND TAKE THE
BEST THINKING AND REACH OUT TO
OUR STAKEHOLDERS TO FIND OUT
WHAT WE COULD DO TO MOST
EFFECTIVELY. MEET THAT THE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA SO- WE SPEND TIME
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FUTURE
HEALTH WORKFORCE COMMISSION
REPORT ILLEGAL REPORTS AND
OTHERS. AND WE'RE VERY FOCUSED
ON TRYING TO BUILD THE PRIMARY
CARE AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE. SO IN TERMS OF
SPECIFIC APPROACHES I'M REALLY
DOES NEED TO START. ALMOST
BEFORE HIGH SCHOOL WE KNOW
THAT- IN UNDERREPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES THERE ARE THE
SCIENCE CLASSES THERE IS IN THE
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW TO GET
INTO HEALTHCARE- PROFESSIONS
AND SO WE REALLY WANT TO FIRST
START WITH THOSE PIPELINE
PROGRAMS. AND THEN EVERY STEP
OF THE WAY HAVE SUPPORTIVE-
MENTORS AND OTHER SUPPORT
PROGRAMS WITHIN THE COLLEGE
SYSTEM AND THEN PROVIDE
SCHOLARSHIPS LOAN REPAYMENT
TRAINING PROGRAMS. AND FRANKLY
CALIFORNIA NEEDS A LOT MORE
RESIDENCY PROGRAM SO WE ARE
TRYING TO- HIT EVERY EVERY
LEVEL OF THE HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE LADDER- TO TRY TO
MEET THAT NEED- ASHIK HAD
HOUSES. THE PRIMARY CARE OFFICE
AND SO WE DO. ANALYSIS EVERY
YEAR TO SEE WHERE THE MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS ARE AND TRY
TO FOCUS OUR RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
ARE SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS ON
THOSE AREAS. WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF PROPOSALS BEFORE- THE
LEGISLATURE TO TRY TO IMPROVE
ON THE STRATEGIC APPROACH THAT
WE TAKE. AND TERMS OF TRYING TO
BUILD RESIDENCY PROGRAMS AND
OTHER TYPES OF TRAINING
PROGRAMS WE NEED MORE COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS WE NEED MORE I'M
AT EVERY LEVEL. AND FRANKLY-
THAT THE NEED IS ALL THE
PRESSING RIGHT NOW- THE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS WORKING AND- OF
AND DOWN SO- PROUD. TO HAVE THE
OPTION JUST TO- HELP SUPPORT
THESE EFFORTS AND WE HAVE A
GREAT TEAM ON ON TAP TO TRY TO
REALLY. WORK AND BUILD A WORK
FORCE THE CALIFORNIA NEEDS.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
THAT VERY OFTEN. IN DEPTH
DISCUSSION ON OUT REALLY
CRITICAL ISSUE- ON I BELIEVE
THAT COVERS MOST F MY
QUESTIONS I JUST ASKED GOING
FORWARD IF YOU'LL KEEP A- US
VERY MUCH IN THE IN THE LOOP ON
ESPECIALLY ON THEIR SIDE.
BEFORE FORTY BILITY TARGET
ISSUE OF BECAUSE OF THAT I'M
I'M RELUCTANT. TO MOVE FORWARD-
TO SUPPORT TODAY BECAUSE I WANT
TO HAVE MORE INFORMATION ON
THAT IF. IF FOR IT WAS STYMIED
I GUESS WHEN IT WAS FIRST
INTRODUCED IN JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC. THAT CREATING-
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE A ON
ANOTHER BUREAUCRACY THAT
ACTUALLY ADDS. A COST BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO HAVE A NEW EMPLOYEES
IN THAT. IS A CONCERN OF MINE
AND CERTAINLY ON ENSURING THAT
ACROSS THE STATE. WE DON'T HAVE
A ONE SIZE FITS ALL BECAUSE WE
ALREADY KNOW THAT. THAT THAT'S
NOT HOW IT WORKS OUT THERE IN
THE REAL. YOU KNOW HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER WORLD SO WITH THAT
THANK YOU FOR ON ANSWERING
QUESTIONS AND I WILL-
CERTAINLY. DIAL BACK WITH YOU
SO WE CAN HAVE MORE IN DEPTH
DISCUSSIONS ON A COUPLE OF
THESE ITEMS THAT. STILL
TROUBLES ME A LITTLE BIT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR THANK
YOU- SENATOR I'M. GOING TO MOVE
TO SENATOR BREAUX. THANK YOU
MADAM. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK THESE
QUESTIONS I TO- IS LANDSBERG
WAS NOT ABLE TO- AND MEET WITH
YOU YESTERDAY AND I DO
APOLOGIZE. IT'S JUST BEEN LIKE
MY COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY
SAID. JUST A HECTIC SCHEDULE
THROUGH THE MONTH OF APRIL. AND
I KNOW WE'RE IN MAY BUT HE
HASN'T SLOWED DOWN YET I DON'T
THINK. AND I DO HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS THAT I DO WANT TO
FOLLOW UP WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM ORANGE COUNTY SENATOR
BATES A VICE YOU'RE ASKED YOU.
ABOUT THE ISSUES ON THE-
TARGETING- COST STRATEGIES FOR
TARGETS OR DEVELOP COST TARGETS
IF- HEALTH PLANS DIDN'T MEET.
THE REDUCTIONS THAT ARE
REQUIRED- YOU SAID THAT YOU
WERE GONNA DO THERE WAS OTHER
STATES THAT ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTED THIS PROGRAM
ALREADY BUT THAT WE WOULD PUT
IT CALIFORNIA'S BAN ON IT. WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN. YES SO- THERE
ARE NUMBER OF STATES THAT HAVE
LOOKED AT AT COST TARGETS I'M
NOT ALL OF THEM DO HAVE AN
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM ON AND WE
THINK THAT IS AN IMPORTANT
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE. WE ALSO
HAVE SPECIFIC PIECES OF THE
OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY THAT WOULD MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE SPENDING ENOUGH
ON PRIMARY CARE AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. AND THERE'S A LOT OF
RESEARCH SHOWING THAT YOU NEED
TO HAVE ADEQUATE INVESTMENT IN
PRIMARY CARE AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH IN ORDER TO TRY TO
PREVENT CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITIONS AND OTHER EXPENSIVE
CARE DOWN THE LINE- WE ALSO
WANT TO PROMOTE ALTERNATE
PAYMENT METHODS. I'M REALLY
LOOKING NOW YOU BASED PAYMENTS
SO THAT DOCTOR PRACTICES HAVE.
THE INVESTMENT THEY NEED- IN
TECHNOLOGY- AND CAN HAVE THE
INVESTMENTS ON ON CARE
MANAGEMENT AND ADDRESSING
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS THOSE
ARE SOME OF THE- I THINK
IMPORTANT PIECES RELATED TO
THAT THE PROPOSED CALIFORNIA.
OFFICES WHAT'S YOUR PORTABILITY.
THANK YOU IN REGARDING THIS
OFFICE- HEALTH CARE. WHAT'S
GONNA BE YOUR ROLE IN THAT. SO
THE OFFICE IS PROPOSED TO BE
WITH AN ARCH THAT INTEL WOULD
BE ONE OF THE OFFICES UNDER ME-
WE HAVE A PROPOSED
ORGANIZATIONAL CHART- WITH THE
STAFF GOING ABOVE A HUNDRED I
WAS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH
THE CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER AND-
WE HAVE AN ADVISORY BOARD.
THAT'S PROPOSED- AND THE
DIRECTOR WOULD OVERSEE A LOT OF
THE WORK MAKING SURE THAT THE
ADVISORY BOARD HAS WHAT THEY
NEED IN TERMS OF THE DATA OUT.
OF AUSTIN WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR PRODUCING A NUMBER OF
REPORTS INCLUDING THE
LEGISLATURE REGARDING THE COSTS
AND THE ISSUE THAT SENATOR
BATES RAISES A CRITICAL ONE
WE'VE REALLY GOT TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THE WHAT ARE THE
PRIMARY COST DRIVERS IN SO BOTH
COLLECTING THE DATA AND THEN
DOING MEANINGFUL ANALYSIS IS
GOING TO BE. KEY TO TRY TO MEET
THAT NEED. SO MEETING WITH MY
HOSPITAL PRESIDENTS IN MY
HOSPITALS IN THE DISTRICT- 50%
OR JUST NORTH OF 50% OF THE
COST TO RUN THE HOSPITAL IS A
LABOR- ABOUT 1815218% IS- THE
DRUG AND PHARMACY. PURCHASES
AND THEN ANOTHER 1112% IN
EITHER PURCHASED- THE STUFF
IT'S REQUIRED. DO YOU THINK
IT'S- A FAIR STATEMENT TO SAY
THAT. YOU KNOW THESE COSTS GO
UP BECAUSE I MEAN POLICIES THAT
GO OUT OF THIS BUILDING I'M NOT
TRYING TO MAKE IT POLITICAL I'M
SAYING THAT. YOU KNOW POLICIES
GO UP RATIO BILLS- ED PLANNING
FOR TWENTY THIRTY AND
RETROFITTING HAVING TO CITY
MANY DECIDE YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO PAY FOR
THAT SOMEHOW. AND BECAUSE
REALLY THEY ARE A BUSINESS I
MEAN- YOU KNOW I REALIZE THAT A
LOT OF THEM ARE YOU KNOW NON
PROFITS AND THEY DO PROVIDE
EXCELLENT SERVICE BUT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT. THESE
HOSPITALS ARE NOT REGULATED OR
LEGISLATED OUT OF BUSINESS
BECAUSE WE NEED PEOPLE TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO CARE- DO YOU.
DO YOU FIND THAT POLICIES THAT
GO OUT OF THIS BUILDING COULD
BE A POSSIBILITY THAT IT'S
CAUSING THE COST INCREASES FOR
HOSPITAL PAYMENTS. THANK YOU
SENATOR BREAUX AS WITH EVERY IN
HEALTHCARE I THINK COSTS AND
HOSPITAL COSTS ARE COMPLICATED.
BUT THE HOT THE OFFICE OF
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY IF
IT'S APPROVED- BY THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD HAVE TO LOOK
AT ALL OF THOSE PIECES SO WOULD
HAVE TO HAVE TO LOOK AT HOW
MUCH ARE LABOR. WAGES
INCREASING BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW
THAT IS A PRIMARY COST OF EVERY
HOSPITAL IF THERE WERE A NEW
MANDATE- THAT WAS IMPOSED THAT
WOULD HAVE TO BE A
CONSIDERATION AS WELL SO. THAT
THE CONCEPT IS TO SET ONE AN
ECONOMIC INDICATOR- AND- AS THE
AS THE COST TARGET SO THAT THAT
WOULD BE TIED TO. INFLATION TO
ECONOMIC CHANGES BUT WE
ABSOLUTELY WOULD ALSO NEED TO
LOOK AT ANY NEW MANDATES THEIR
HOST ON HOSPITALS. OKAY AND
THEN THEM. ON THIS OUR OFFICE
OF HEALTH CARE ACCOUNTABILITY
IT. NUMBER ONE IT'S GOING TO
PROVIDE MORE TRANSPARENCY. IN
THE PRICE. AND QUALITY OF
HEALTHCARE NUMBER TO DEVELOP
COST STARGATES IN DIFFERENT
AREAS OF HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY.
NUMBER THREE DEVELOP
ACCOUNTABILITY FRAMEWORK
INCLUDING FINANCIAL PENALTIES.
FOR HEALTH CARE ENTITIES THAT
DON'T MEET THESE COST TARGETS-
WHEN THESE COST TARGETS ARE SET
AND THERE'S JUST NOT A REAL WAY
ON THE GROUND TO BE ABLE TO
MEET THESE TARGETS BASED ON.
THE OBLIGATIONS THAT HOSPITALS
HAVE ALREADY HAVE IN AND YOU
KNOW THAT HOSPITALS ALREADY
HAVING. TO MAINTAIN OUR HEALTH
PLANS ARE HAVING TO PAY FOR-
THIS PARTICULAR QUESTION IS
HEALTH. SO IF HEALTH PLANS CAN.
REDUCE THE COST TO MEET THOSE
REQUIREMENTS AND THERE ARE
TARGETS FIT IN PLACE. AND I
GUESS I'M JUST GOING TO ASK YOU
POINT BLANK IS THIS A PLANNER
POLICY THAT IS MOVING US TO A
SINGLE PAYER HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
NO THIS IS NOT MOVED TO A
SINGLE PAYER HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
THIS TRULY IS ABOUT-
TRANSPARENCY UNDERSTANDING THE
COST DRIVERS AND SETTING COST
TARGET SO- EVERY PART OF THE
PROCESS WOULD START WITH TRYING
TO WITH CAPTURING DATA ON THE
TOTAL COST OF CARE LOOKING AT
PREMIUMS LOOKING AT WHAT
INDIVIDUAL CONSUMERS ARE PAYING
AND DEDUCTIBLES- IN COPAYS.
LOOKING INTO MINISTRY BECAUSE
TAKING THAT TOTAL COST OF CARE
AND SETTING A COSTS ARE GOING
TO GET IT COULD BE AT THE RATE
OF INFLATION IT COULD BE TO THE
GDP- AND THEN HAVING THAT APPLY
TO- MOST MEMBERS. OF THE
HEALTHCARE MARKET BUT THERE'S
NOTHING DIRECTLY RELATED TO THE
SINGLE PAYER NOW MA'AM. IS
THERE A PLAN TO- STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS FOR PERMITTING FOR
CHANGES OR- BUILDING GOING BACK
TO THE BUILDINGS OF HOSPITALS
AND- RETROFITTING AND YOU KNOW
WINGS BEING ADDED. BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THERE'S- EVERY OTHER STATE
HAS SOME TYPE OF CONCEPTUAL
PROCESS FROM BEGINNING TO END.
BUT CALIFORNIA DOESN'T AND-
THEY DON'T WE DON'T EVEN START
WITH A COMPLETE PROCESS BEFORE
CONSTRUCTION ON THE PROJECT
EVEN GET STARTED AND THEM. IT'S
VERY FRUSTRATING FOR A LOT OF
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE TRYING
TO MEET THESE NEEDS THE
STANDARDS THAT ARE SET OUT OF
THIS BUILDING AND ALSO- AND
DEAL WITH THE RETROFITTING
ISSUE. IT'S GENERALLY SPEAKING
IT'S ABOUT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
A BAD FOR CONSTRUCTION. IN
CALIFORNIA VERSES ABOUT EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
MOST MOST OTHER STATES. IN THE
HOSPITAL- THE PEOPLE THAT THE
HOSPITAL WORK WITH ENGINEERS
THOSE KINDS INDIVIDUALS THAT
BUILD THESE MEGA SHIPS
MAGNIFICENT DISABILITIES- IT'S
BECAUSE OF THE DELAY IN THE
APPROVAL PROCESS AND THE
PROCESS ITSELF IS THERE A- IS
THERE A WAY THAT YOU COULD
POSSIBLY HAVE YOUR TEAM LOOK AT
THE PROCESS AND HOW IT'S
CONTINUALLY DELAYED AND- MAINLY
HAVE A- A CONCEPT FROM
BEGINNING TO END FOR
CONSTRUCTION AND NOT JUST KEEP
MOVING IT IF THAT MAKES SENSE.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROW SO IT'S
TRUE THAT AUSTIN DOES THAT THE
BUILDING STANDARDS- AND THOSE
ARE SET IN CODE. AND WE HAVE A
HOSPITAL BUILDING SAFETY BOARD
WITH MANY MEMBERS OF THE
HOSPITAL INDUSTRY AS WELL AS
OTHERS THAT PARTICIPATE IN THAT
SO THERE ARE STANDARDS. THAT WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE ARE HERE TOO
BUT IN THE CONTEXT OF THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN OPTION HAD STRUCTURAL
ENGINEERS AND ARCHITECTS IN
LIFE AND SAFETY FOLKS A LOT OF
BACK AND FORTH TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE NEEDS OF THE HOSPITAL
ALL. DO A LOT. HAVING AND
APPROACHES OF HOW THEY MAY BE
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THEIR
BUILDINGS ALL WITHIN THE
CONFINES OF BUILDING STANDARDS
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO LOOK AT- AT
SPECIFIC APPROACHES BUT- AGAIN
MY TEAM HAS MADE A LOT OF
STRIDES IN THE LAST DECADE TO
INNOVATE TO TRY TO HAVE A
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH WITH
HOSPITALS TO MEET THE SHARED
GOAL OF SENATE HAVING THIS
HOSPITALS MEET STANDARDS AND
MAINTAIN PATIENT SAFETY WHILE
ALSO HAVING IN. A PROCESS THAT
WORKS FOR ALL PARTIES AND THANK
YOU FOR THAT I THINK WE ARE THE
ISSUES I THINK WE JUST HAVE A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION ON AND A
TIMELY PROCESS I MEAN IT TOOK
ALMOST THIRTY YEARS TO BUILD A
HOUSE BUT WHEN I HAVE TO HAVE
TO BE AREA- AND- IT WAS THE ARE
SPREAD PROCESS THAT STOP TO
THAT HOSPITAL FROM MOVING
FORWARD AFTER TO BONDS AND- IT
WAS A VERY DIFFICULT AND THAT'S
A REAL COMMUNITY IT. HAD- JEFF
UNTIL LAST YEAR THE YEAR JUST
TWO YEARS AGO TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN CODE KIND OF THROWS ME
OFF SO I APOLOGIZE BUT- JUST
RECENTLY THE DAY HAD MOVED FROM
A HOSPITAL THAT WERE THEY WERE
STILL WILLING OXYGEN BOTTLES
DOWN THE HALLWAY AND THEY HAD
CONCRETE. AND CINDER BLOCKS
WHERE THE NURSES STATION WAS.
AND IT TOOK A LONG TIME TO GET
INTO A STATE OF THE ART
FACILITY AND BECAUSE OF THE
PROCESS THAT THEY HAVE TO GO
THROUGH. WITH US BED SO- WE'RE
GOOD WE'VE BUILT OUR HOSPITAL
BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF OTHER-
COMMUNITIES THAT I HEAR FROM
THAT ARE GOING THROUGH THE SAME
PROCESS. TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE GOT IT DONE IN YOU KNOW
LESS THAN FORTY YEARS IT'S I
JUST THINK THAT TIME FRAME. IS
SIGNIFICANT I THINK WE CAN
BUILD A STATE OF THE ART
HOSPITAL. IN A IN A SOONER TIME
FRAME THAN THAT SO IF YOU WOULD
LOOK AT THAT I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. WE'LL CERTAINLY
DO SO THANK YOU MA'AM. THANK
YOU MA'AM SORRY NOT JUST MAKING
SURE ARE YOU FINISHED THANK YOU
SENATOR GROW- SENATOR COM
LOCKER. THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM
UM AND SO GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO-
CHAT. EARLIER TODAY AND- I
SHARED WITH YOU THAT I AM
EXCITED ABOUT. YOUR APPOINTMENT
IN THE OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY
IMPLEMENT. BIG BOLD MEASURES
AND THOSE ARE THINGS I HANG
THAT CALIFORNIA TENDS TO PRIDE
ITSELF ON AND SO- WE I THINK
WE'LL BE ROOTING FOR THE
SUCCESS COMING OUT OF THIS
DEPARTMENT WE TALKED ABOUT A
FEW THINGS THAT I WANT TO
ELEVATE- CLEAN THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING IF YOU DON'T MIND. THE
FIRST OF WHICH WAS THE-
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICING- AND
WE KNOW THAT- WITH OSCAR PET
DRUG MANUFACTURERS ARE REQUIRED
TO NOTIFY YOU ALL- I GUESS WHEN
THEY'RE INTRODUCING A NEW DRUG
INTO THE MARKET PLACE OR WHEN
THERE'S AN INCREASE IN PRICING-
AND- I THINK YOU ALL HAD ISSUED
I THINK SINCE TWENTY NINETEEN.
ABOUT SIXTY TWO PENALTIES
TOTALING OVER SIXTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS BUT HAD ONLY
COLLECTED ROUGHLY SIX AND A
HALF MILLION- IN FINES. AND
JUST WANTED TO KNOW- IF YOU
COULD SHARE WHY THE
COLLECTIONS- ARE SO LOW
ESPECIALLY SINCE WE TALKED
ABOUT ENFORCEMENT I WAS LOOKING
AT THOSE NUMBERS THINKING WE
BETTER GET OUR MONEY. THANK YOU
SENATOR AKAKA LAWYER SO- I SAID
DOES CONSIDER THE BECAUSE-
REASONING FOR LATE SUBMISSIONS
SO. IF A DRUG COMPANY HAS
AGREED BECAUSE WE DO A
SETTLEMENT NEGOTIATION PROCESS
WITH THEM TO HEAR ANY SPECIFIC
PARTICULAR CONCERNS. OR LACK OF
INFORMATION OR- IN THE
BEGINNING ADMITTEDLY THERE ARE
SOME- TECHNICAL PROBLEMS JUST
WAS SUBMITTING SOME OF THE
REPORTING SO IF ANY OF THAT'S
THE CASE WE HAVE SHOWN
LENIENCY- WE ALSO WERE MORE
FOCUSED AT THE- BEGINNING OF
THE PROGRAM AND MAKING SURE
THAT THE MANUFACTURERS.
UNDERSTOOD OR COMPLYING. WITH
THE REQUIREMENTS BUT IT'S BEEN
LONG ENOUGH AND IT'S TIME FOR
MANUFACTURERS TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT OUR REPORTING AND NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS ARE AND SO WE ARE
BEING A LITTLE MORE SERIOUS
ABOUT- MAKING SURE WE'RE OR BY
GETTING FOR COLLECTING ON THOSE
FINES. ON A RECENT APPEAL I DID
ISSUE A DECISION SUSTAINING AT
TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR
PENALTY AGAINST A
PHARMACEUTICAL MANUFACTURER
THAT FAIL TO PROVIDE TIMELY
REPORTING- AND DIDN'T HAVE A
GOOD REASON AND SO WE HOPE
THAT- MANUFACTURES WILL BE ON
NOTICE THAT WE'RE TAKING THIS
SERIOUSLY. AND WE DO NEED THEM
TO COMPLY. THANK YOU FOR THAT
YOU'LL HAVE TO TELL THEM
THERE'S A NEW. IN I DIDN'T I
NUMBER COLLEAGUES HAVE ASKED
ABOUT THE SEISMIC SAFETY ISSUES
AND SO I WILL- REALLY BE LABOR
THAT BUT AS I MENTIONED WITH
YOU I'VE- SEEN A COUPLE OF
LETTERS I THINK FROM THE
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION REALLY
ASKING FOR SOME FLEXIBILITY
WITH REGARDS TO- THE COMPLIANCE
ISSUES BECAUSE OF CODED AND THE
COSTS. THAT THEY'VE HAD T- FOR
ABSORB- AND SO JUST WANTED TO
KNOW IF YOU COULD. TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW TO THREAD
THAT NEEDLE NEON THE
FLEXIBILITY ISSUE WITH
COMPLIANCE. AND ALSO WITH
REALITY BECAUSE THE REALITY IS
THAT THERE ARE QUITE A FEW
HOSPITALS WHO HAVE- RAKED IN A
NUMBER OF PROFITS HAVE HAD A
GOOD YEAR AS A RESULT OF LAST
YEAR- AND SO I DO THINK THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT ELEVATE VAST.
AND TALK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF MAKING SURE THAT OUR
HOSPITALS ARE STAYING IN
COMPLIANCE WITH WHAT IS
REQUIRED FROM THEM BY THE STATE.
THANK YOU SO I MEAN I THINK THE
GOOD NEWS IS THAT CALIFORNIA'S
HOSPITALS HAVE REALLY COME A
LONG WAY IN THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS. I'M IN THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS THERE WERE MORE THAN
THIRTEEN HUNDRED. THANK YOU
HOSPITAL BUILDINGS THAT WERE AT
RISK OF COLLAPSE- INTERFACE AND
THAT IS DOWN TO ONLY A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY THREE BUILDINGS-
THEY'RE WHAT WE CALL S. PC ONE
THAT THE SEISMIC PERFORMANCE
CATEGORY ONE. SO HOSPITALS HAVE
COME A LONG WAY WORKING WITH
AUSTIN TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
BUILDINGS ARE SAFE. AND YES WE
KNOW THAT THE PANDEMIC HAS PUT
AN UNUSUAL STRAIN ON HOSPITALS-
BUT THE WORK DOES NEED TO
CONTINUE. WE UNDERSTAND THE
HOSPITAL SO IT'S THE ISSUE MAY
HAVE A PROPOSAL ON IT WILL AS
ALWAYS PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- ON THAT PROPOSAL.
SO YOU MEANT A HUNDRED AND
THEIR HOUSE. IS DO YOU DAHLE
GENERALLY WHERE THEY'RE
LOCATED- THERE ARE THEY
SPRINKLED THROUGHOUT THE STATE
TODAY TEND TO BE AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES ARE URBAN
COMMUNITIES ARE DENSER. DO WE
HAVE ANY OF THAT INFORMATION.
WE DO HAVE A GEO MAP OF THAT
AND- THEY ARE- THEY ARE SPREAD
OUT THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AS
ONE WOULD EXPECT IF YOU LOOK AT
THE MAP THERE CERTAINLY
BLUSTERY YOUR AREA AND IN LOS
ANGELES. AS WELL AS IN THE BAY
AREA- BUT THERE ARE SOME RURAL
HOSPITALS AS WELL AND SO. THOSE
HOSPITALS ARE IN AREAS- DO
THIS- VARIOUS. PHASES ALONG THE
WAY IN TERMS OF SOME OF THEM
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
RETROFITTING SOME OF THEM MAY
BE USED FOR OTHER PURPOSES.
SOME OF THEM MAY BE
DECOMMISSIONED- SO. BUT THEY
THEY ARE SPREAD OUT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WHEN WE I BELIEVE.
WE'VE SHARED A MAP AND IF NOT
WE'LL FOLLOW UP AND ARE HAPPY
TO DO SO. I AM SO I. WE DID
TALK A- ABOUT OKEH- AND AS I
MENTIONED THAT IS BIG AND BOLD.
SO THIS IS MY LAST QUESTION
WHICH- WE ALSO DISCUSSED IN.
GIVEN THE ENORMOUS TASK AHEAD
OF YOU- AND THE COMPLEXITY AND
ENORMITY OF THE ISSUE OF
AFFORDABLE HEALTHCARE- AND HOW
TO MAKE SURE THAT. EVERY
CALIFORNIAN HAS ACCESS TO IT-
AND I KNOW THAT'S NOT YEAH I
MEAN YOU DON'T HAVE A MAGIC
WAND TO DO ALL OF THAT BUT YOU
ARE IN A REAL POSITION TO HELP
MAKE THAT MANIFEST. WAS JUST
WONDERING IF YOU COULD SHARE-
WHAT KEEPS YOU UP AT NIGHT
THINKING ABOUT. ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR AND THE ENORMOUS TASK IN
FRONT OF YOU. WELL CERTAINLY
MAKING SURE THAT OUR HOSPITALS
ARE SAFE ON THE CRITICAL
FUNCTION OF OXFORD AND
SOMETHING THAT I TAKE VERY
SERIOUSLY- RIGHT NOW WITH THE-
WITH THE COVETED CRISIS AND I
THINK REALLY HAS WILL. TAKE A
COMBINATION OF THE COVERED
CRISIS THE ECONOMIC PAIN THAT
FOLKS ARE UNDER AND THEIR
RECOGNITION OF OUR COUNTRY'S
MANY HUNDRED YEARS A RACIAL
INEQUALITY HAS LED TO REALLY A
HUGE. SPIKE IN BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH NEEDS AND SO WE REALLY
WANT TO BE LASER FOCUSED AS WE
LOOK TO OUR WORK FORCE PROGRAMS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE HELPING
BUILD THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE. THE CALIFORNIA NEEDS
MAKING SURE THAT PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS ARE TRAINED TO DO
SCREENING FOR DEPRESSION AND
OTHER. BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS- MANY TO START A
YOUNG OLD WITH WITH CHILDREN
AND THAT THE GOVERNOR AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN A
LEADER ON THAT SO- HOSPITAL
SAFETY THE WORK FORCE THE
CALIFORNIA NEEDS THAT THAT
REFLECTS THE DIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA. AND THEN VERY
EXCITED TO HOPEFULLY DELVE INTO
THIS NEW OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY WHICH IS
ENORMOUSLY COMPLEX- BUT THERE
ARE A LOT OF OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE DONE IT WELL- THAT WE ALL
LEARN FROM. AND I KNOW THAT WE
CAN MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE IN
TRYING TO THE END THIS IS NOT
ABOUT CONTROLLING COSTS ONLY WE
DON'T WANT TO RACE TO THE
BOTTOM WE WANT A HIGH VALUE
SYSTEM. THAT MAINTAINS QUALITY
HOPEFULLY IMPROVES QUALITY IN
EQUITY OVER TIME THROUGH THE
INVESTMENTS IN PRIMARY AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE- THAT
CONTROLS COSTS- THAT WE HAVE A
HUGE IMPACT ON PEOPLE'S LIVES.
AS WELL AS SUPPLIERS AND STATE.
WELL YOU KNOW I WANNA THANK YOU-
FOR THAT RESPONSE AND FOR ALL
OF YOUR WRIST- I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING YOU. AS I
LISTEN TO YOU IT REMINDS ME
THAT HEALTHCARE IS SUCH A
PERSONAL ISSUE AND IT REALLY
GOES TO THE CORE. OF HOW WE SEE
OURSELVES AND HOW WE VALUE
OURSELVES. AND HOW ARE
COMMUNITIES SEE AND VALUE US.
YOU KNOW SO MANY FOLKS- WITH
ETHNIC BACKGROUNDS WOMEN ARE
FOLKS WHO ARE A POOR FOLKS WHO
WERE LIVING IN DIFFERENT YOU
KNOW COMMUNITIES IF IT'S RURAL
FOLKS ARE LGBT- FOLKS WHO'VE
WHO'VE BEEN IN THE MILITARY MAN
I MEAN EVERYONE COMES WITH A
STORY. ABOUT HOW THEY SEE THEIR
BODY. AND HOW THEY TAKE CARE OF
IT- AND I REALLY THINK THAT
YOUR DEPARTMENT- IS HELPING
CALIFORNIA GET TO THE CORE OF
HOW WE ANSWER ALL OF THOSE
ISSUES. AND QUESTIONS WITH SOME
COMPASSION WHILE MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE DOING IT IN A WAY
THAT DOESN'T BANKRUPT YOU KNOW
THE STATE OR THE PROVIDERS THAT
ARE HERE. AND I THINK WE ALL
KNOW THAT IF WE HAVE HEALTHY
CALIFORNIANS THAT WE HAVE A
HEALTHY STATE SO THAT'S I'M
GOING TO GET OFF THE SOAPBOX
MANNA PRO TEM- BUT I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THIS TIME- MISS
LANDSBERG AND LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SENATOR COM LONGER- I.
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST A
CONVERSATION AND DISCUSSION
AND- MISS LANDSBERGER YOUR LAST
STATEMENT SEEMED LIKE A
COMPILATION AND CONCLUSION OF
THE VISION- AND I APPRECIATE
THAT AND I APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS. SO I
DON'T REALLY HAVE ANYTHING TO
ADD EXCEPT I DO APPRECIATE THE-
THE BOLD. MOVE FORWARD LEARN
FROM WHAT OTHER STATES HAVE
DONE. I MAKE SURE THAT WE PUT
IT THROUGH THE LENS OF OUR
VALUES POLICIES AND BELIEFS-
AND I WISH YOU THE BEST IN
THAT- WE ARE GONNA I DO LIKE
YOUR ENTHUSIASM I MIGHT ADD-
AND CERTAINLY YOU HAVE THE
EXPERTISE- TO TAKE ON THIS
TASK. I'M GONNA RECOMMEND ONLY
SORRY THAT I WASN'T ABLE TO- TO
WORK IN GOLDEN GIRLS BUT
SENATOR. LARRY DIDN'T HEAR ME
OUT. THERE'S ALWAYS A DAY AND-
SOMEHOW THINK YOU'VE WORKED IN-
WHO'S STILL IN TIME BUT I THINK
YOU WORKED IT IN ANYWAY. AND
WITH THAT ARE I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT WE MOVED TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. WHO WANT
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT THAT'S
WHERE WE'LL START AND AS A
REMINDER AGAIN FOR WITNESSES
WISHING TO PROVIDE COMMENT VIA
PHONE THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER IS GOING TO APPEAR
AGAIN. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. THREE THREE
EIGHT ZERO FOUR SIX SEVEN. AND
WE'RE GONNA START RIGHT HERE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE AND
I DON'T SEE ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC THAT HAS ARRIVED TO
TESTIFY. SO I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND LOOK AT ROOM ONE TWELVE
JUST TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
COVERING OUR BASES. I DON'T SEE
ANYONE APPROACHING THE PODIUM
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE SO MADAM
MODERATOR YOU HAVE BEEN WAITING
IN THE WINGS LET ME WELCOME YOU
BACK. AND ASK IF YOU WILL T. OP
PEOPLE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. I REQUEST YOU LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND AS
WE WAIT FOR THOSE PEOPLE TO TEE
UP I WILL AGAIN REMIND OUR
WITNESSES THAT WHEN YOU SPEAK.
PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION IF ANY. AND YOU'RE
VERY BRIEF POSITION ON THE
APPOINTMENT AND AGAIN ON BEHALF
OF OUR COURT REPORTER PLEASE
SPEAK SLOWLY AND CLEARLY.
MADAME MODERATOR IF YOU WANT TO
OPEN THE LINES AND GO AHEAD- WE
INVITE YOU TO DO THAT. GREAT
THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN- MEDICARE
MEMBERS CONNIE DELGADO ON
BEHALF OF TWO POINTS. WE HAVE
TO DISTRICT HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP
FORUM. WE USED TO SUPPORT THE-
CONFIRMATION OF THE PLANTS
BURKE SHOPPERS AT THAT HAVE
EXPERIENCE AND KNOWLEDGE WHICH
WE FEEL QUALIFIED THIRD SERVICE
DIRECTOR IN A PREVIOUS
RESPONSIBILITIES SHE'S SHOWN
THAT SHE IS UNIQUELY QUALIFIED
TO LEAD THE OFFICE STATE WIDE
HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT. THE DISTRICT
HOSPITALS LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HER ON MANY. OF
THE ISSUES DISCUSSED TODAY.
THANK YOU HAVE OF THE COUNT I'M
AHEAD OF THE CURVE BECAME.
HEALTH DIRECTOR BARRY HAD A
SURE TWENTY HALF OF THE COUNTY
DIRECTOR OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE WANT
TO SUPPORT THE CONFIRMATION OF
APPOINTMENT LANDSBURG.
ADMINISTERS FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN WORKFORCE EDUCATION
AND TRAINING WORK GRANTS
AUTHORIZED BY THE LEGISLATURE
TO HELP BUILD OUT MENTAL
HEALTH. AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER WORKFORCE FOR COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL. HEALTH DIRECTOR
AGENCIES. BASED ON THE
IMPORTANCE AUSTIN BY THE PUBLIC
BEHAVE HEALTH NET ACCOUNT
BEHAVIORAL HOW DIRECT APPROVED
THE CONFIRMATION. LANDSBERG
HAVE DEMONSTRATED TRUE
LEADERSHIP AND COMMITMENT TO
WORK AND SUPPORT THE MISSION OF
THE ADMINISTRATION IN AUSTIN AS
WELL AS THE WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS. AND
THEIR COLLEAGUES- RESPECTFULLY
ASK THE- I THOUGHT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND FORGIVE ME MR
GATOT FOR INTERRUPTING YOU-
MADAME MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT OPEN MY NUMBER FIFTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS YES MEAN PALETTE ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE CONFIRMATION OF A LITTLE
BIT LANDSBERG AS DIRECTOR. OF
ACCESS HAS WORKED WITH MISS
LAND BURKE FOR OVER SIXTEEN
YEARS AND MULTIPLE DIFFERENT
CAPACITIES. FIRST HEALTH
ADVOCATE FOR WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY ALSO DURING HER
YEARS AT THE HMO HELP CENTER AT
THE MHD AND IN HER NEW ROLE AT
OSHKOSH WE ARE WORKING MORE
CLOSELY WITH HER THAN ANY OF
HER PRESENT PREDECESSORS. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK CLOSELY WITH HER AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
LOOK TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. ONE
FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
HI MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO SHELLY REQUIRED I AM
THE FORMER DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE HAPPY TO SUPPORT
ELIZABETH LANDSBERG- NOMINATION
SHOULD BE THAT DIRECTOR AT
ASHTON- I WORKED WITH ELISABETH
GROVER TWENTY YEARS IN VARIOUS
CAPACITIES IN THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM AND I CAN. ATTEST TO
HER- HER HIGH LEVEL OF
INTEGRITY AND ETHICS SHE IS
TRULY A- PUBLIC SERVANT THAT IS
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE THAT
CONSUMERS ARE PROTECTED AND
THAT THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
WORKS AS IT SHOULD CRAWLING. SO
I JUST WANTED TO ADD MY
PERSONAL PLACE TO ENCOURAGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR HER
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. UNION ILLEGAL
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF KAISER
PERMANENTE SAY HE BEGAN AT THE
PORT OF ELIZABETHTOWN PREFER
DIRECTOR OF AUSTIN HAD A WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HER ON THE MANY ISSUES FACING
HEALTHCARE ORGANIZATIONS NOW
AND IN THE FUTURE AND WOULD
URGE YOU TO. SUPPORT THIS
NOMINATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. ONE FIFTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ZACHRY CORBEAU WITH
C. CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION WISHING TO ECHO THE
SUPPORTIVE COMMENTS OF THOSE
UNSPOKEN BEFORE US- MISLIM
BURKE IS ALREADY ACTIVELY
ENGAGED WITH CDA IN HER
CAPACITY AS DIRECTOR WITH A
FOCUS ON THE DENTAL WORK FORCE
IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO A CONTINUED DIALOGUE.
AS WE COORDINATE WITH HER
INDEED APARTMENTS NEW ITERATION
AND WITH THE OFFICE OF ORAL
HEALTH ON WORKFORCE ISSUES AND
SHORTAGES IMPACTING DENTAL
OFFICES WE'RE PLEASED TO
UNCONDITIONALLY SUPPORT HER AND
HER TONIGHT BUT- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. ONE
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHANCE
LAURIE ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WE
ARE THRILLED TO UNCONDITIONALLY
SUPPORT UNITS LANDSBERG- SHE
WORKED WITH THAT FOR A DECADE-
BOTH AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE AND IT'S OUR DIRECTOR
POLICY ADVOCACY MANY PEOPLE IN
THE CAPITAL ARE FAMILIAR WITH
THE ROLE THAT SHE PLAYED. IN
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT IN
CALIFORNIA SHE WAS ONE OF A
HANDFUL OF CONSUMER ADVOCATE
THAT WOULD ALWAYS AT THE TABLE
AND- LEGISLATION WAS BEING
DRAFTED REGULATIONS WERE BEING
DRAFTED- AND THE COURT AND THE
CONSUMER EXPERIENCE
PARTICULARLY THOSE LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS ON MEDIC COW- HURTING
THEIR PRINTS ARE STILL ALL OVER
THIS LAW AND ARE PART OF THE
REASON THAT. I HEALTH REFORM
IMPLEMENTATION IN CALIFORNIA
WHAT THAT PICKED THAT UP- I
ALSO HAD OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH HER OUT WHILE SHE WAS AT
WESTERN CENTER ON FIRST IN THE
NATION LEGISLATION. THAT
PROVIDED ADDITIONAL CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AROUND MEDICAL
CREDIT CARDS THAT ARE OFFERED
TO CONSUMERS SUCH AS WELL AS
THE STRONGEST PROTECTION ON
BALANCE BILLING TO MEDICAID
CONSUMERS IN THE COUNTRY- ON A
PERSONAL NOTE I JUST WANT TO
DATE THAT MEANS LANDSBERG HOLD
YOURSELF TO A LEVEL OF
EXCELLENCE THAT PERMEATE YOUR
LIFE. HE DOESN'T TAKE SHORT
CUTS EVEN IF THAT MEANS HAVING
DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS. THAT
THAT SHE DRAWS ON WHICH YOU
HAVE TO MAKE TOUGH DECISIONS
WELL AT THE SAME TIME SHE COULD
HEAR CRITICISM AND GROW FROM
IT. IS ALWAYS BETTER HOMEWORK
BEFORE ENTERING A SITUATION AND
SHE EXPECTS RESULT CALIFORNIA
WOULD BE WELL SERVED TO HAVE A
LOOK AT A GLANCE BURKE AS
DIRECTOR OF THE HOSTAGE-
PARTICULARLY AS ITS ROLE IS
BEING RECONSIDERED AND AS THEIR
ON- BARKING ON NEW ACTIVITIES
LIKE THE OFFICE OF. HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. AND BEFORE WE
OPEN ONE FIFTY EIGHT AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO ACTIVE TIME FIVE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS BARBARA
PLATE WITH A CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION. AHA IN
OUR MEMBERS HAVE WORKED WITH
MISS PLANNED FOR PER NUMBER OF
YEAR. FROM MY TIME WORKING WITH
THE PLAN FOR WE KNOW THAT SHE
POSSESSES THE KNOWLEDGE AND
DISCIPLINE. TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY ON THE COMPLEX
CHALLENGES FACING OUR
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM. A
DEEP BACKGROUND IN HEALTH CARE
POLICY MISS PLAN THIRD BRING TO
THIS LEADERSHIP POST. WILL BE
CRITICAL AS WE WORK
COLLECTIVELY TO RECOVER FROM
THE SETBACK THE COSBY NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. IMPROVE THE
AFFORDABILITY OF HEALTHCARE. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE MID
PLAN FOR BE CONFIRMED AS
DIRECTOR POSH PAD. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
BETTER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS GLAZER ANY FURTHER-
TESTIMONY OR WITNESSES. NOT
THIS TIME HAVE NO ONE OF IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR WE'LL BE BACK JUST A
MOMENT. SO HAVING HEARD FROM
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT. WE WILL MOVE TO-
ANYONE WHO MIGHT BE IN
OPPOSITION WILL START AGAIN
HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE AND AGAIN. WE HAVE NOT HAD
ANYONE- ARRIVE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION FROM THE PUBLIC IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. SO
I WILL. FOR THE LAST TIME LOOK
AT ROOM ONE TWELVE. AND SEE
THAT THERE IS NO ONE APPROACH
IN THE PODIUM IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE SO MADAM MODERATOR I
COME BACK TO YOU ALREADY FOR
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO ACTIVE TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
APPETITE. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION. TO MODERATOR THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE
SUPPORT TODAY WE APPRECIATE IT.
AND WITH OUR THANKS I WILL COME
BACK TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND SENATOR COM
LONGER I THINK YOU ARE PREPARED
TO MAKE A MOTION. THAT'S RIGHT
SO MOVED SO MOVED- MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. GROWTH AND ABSTAINED
GROVE NOT NEGATIVE STAINING
GROVE NOT VOTING. KAMLAGER I AM
LONGER AYE LAYERED AYE LAYERED
AYE BATES NOT VOTING IT'S NOT
VOTING ATKINS HI ATKINS FIVE
THREE TO ZERO THAT'S THREE
VOTES TO MOVE THE CONFIRMATION
FORWARD TO THE SENATE FLOOR
MISS LANCE BURKE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY WE
APPRECIATED AND CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
OKAY THIS CONCLUDES TODAY'S
AGENDA LET ME SAY THANK YOU TO
ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY. IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE OR YOU CAN
VISIT OUR WEBSITE FOR
INSTRUCTIONS YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE TRULY IMPORTANT
TO US AND WE DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS STILL AT ME
THANK MY COLLEAGUES AND MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC AND STAFF ALL FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND COOPERATION.
AND WITH THAT ARE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES IS NOW
ADJOURNED THANK YOU.